this is joco podcast number 342
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
the explosion rocked them the blast
deafening in the night
for an instant it let their lit their
dirty blood-smeared faces their hollow
eyes set in hopeless determination
a few more shells crashed around them
none as close as the first
each blinding flash shone upon the
corpses lying across the battlefield
gruesome evidence of the fight that had
raged over the past days
hundreds lay dead over the hilltop
outpost
the bodies of south vietnamese
paratroopers mixed with those of their
determined north vietnamese enemy
the hellacious battle had allowed the
paratroopers to recover only some of
their fallen comrades
they'd wrapped a number in their plastic
ponchos and placed them in trenches
that was a while ago earlier in the
fight when there'd been time to render a
modicum of respect
later they'd stacked bodies in rows as
they were able
most of the dead though were strewn
where they'd been cut down in the last
hours of combat
punctured torn dismembered and shredded
grotesque reflections of their final
violent seconds of life
the explosion stopped
the dark returned
only the moans of the wounded pierced
the silence of the night
the stench of death filled the nostrils
of the last two men fighting
smoke choked their lungs
they waited in anticipation
they heard orders shouted from across
the field
they sensed movement as another attack
wave swept toward them
the american advisor leaned close to his
vietnamese counterpart and exclaimed
[__]
here they come again
the reply in broken but well-practiced
english was resolute i know
we fight
we fight more
the enemy once again rose from the
darkness tearing through the night
coming at them as vague shapes screaming
and shooting throwing grenades as they
advance closer and closer still
both u.s army adviser special forces
major john joseph duffy and south
vietnamese major lee van may
the senior surviving battalion officer
knew this was the final assault
bullets whizzed by them a grenade
exploded ripping a hole in major may's
chest
he gasped for air
john duffy already wounded several times
himself
looked over his left shoulder
he nodded satisfied seeing the decimated
force all that was left of the once
mighty 11th airborne battalion escaping
down the hillside
john and may the rear guard were all
that stood between the remnants of the
battalion
and their annihilation
they'd been out of food for days
they had no water left in their canteens
their ammunition was nearly gone
but still the american and his south
vietnamese comrade fought
and still the enemy came
there was no talk of surrender
no thought but to kill as many as they
could before they were themselves cut
down where they squatted on the edge of
their abandoned positions
lee van may strain to speak
fight duffy fight
they battled with everything that
remained in their hearts and souls
but the end of their road was only
minutes away
they knew they were about to die
and that right there is the opening
of
an incredible book which is called
extraordinary valor
which is about the defense
of
charlie hill in vietnam
and this book is written by
retired colonel william reader who was a
helicopter pilot in vietnam who has been
on this podcast before podcast number 63
and on that podcast we discussed
colonel reader's first book which is
called through the valley
which follows colonel readers combat
experiences from flying a ov1 mohawk in
support of secret missions in north
vietnam laos and cambodia eventually
switching to pilot the ah-1 g cobra
gunship
from the 361st aerial weapons company
callsign pink panther and it was in that
duty
that colonel reader was shot down
evaded the enemy for three days was
eventually captured
imprisoned in a jungle prison camp
tortured mock executed and finally
forced
to march
north to the hanoi hilton
and in that grueling
march
where
seven of the 26 pows in his group
were killed
and upon arriving at the hanoi hilton
where he suffered the rest of his
with the rest of his american pows until
he was finally released after 320 days
of captivity
so to hear that story
go listen to that podcast and and to get
the actual full story
get the book through the valley
there are it's it's a harrowing story
and so many lessons to be learned
but prior to that ordeal
then captain reader
flew in direct support
of
major duffy
and the defense of charlie hill
and he knew that that was a story of
courage and valor that needed to be
shared
so he spent
years
compiling data and reviewing records and
interviewing participants and giving his
own personal account in this book
extraordinary valor
and it is an honor
to have colonel reader here with us
again
to discuss this new book
and his experiences from this battle and
how this battle unfolded
colonel reader
thank you for joining us again it's an
honor to have you thank you jacob
so
what made you decide to write this book
there's a little bit of a story involved
so i will go ahead and share it
when i wrote my first book on my
captivity
that book wasn't published until
2016 as i remember so that was decades
after after that experience in vietnam
but it was a book that i had wanted to
write i just never found the time
staying on active duty commanding units
it was just always too busy
finally i found the time sat down and
started to put pen to paper and all of
these memories and recollections that i
thought were right there because i had
lived that experience
when i started writing yes some of those
recollections were right there i
remember things crystal clear
other things after all those years were
a little bit fuzzy
so i wanted to be sure that i had all of
my information correct all my facts
correct uh particularly in the in the
war that led up to my getting shot down
and captured
so i would talk to guys from my unit
that i could get a hold of talk to
return prisoners that i had been with to
be sure i had everything as as right as
could be
one of the battles that i mentioned and
i think it only gets a few paragraphs in
my first book was this battle at
firebase charlie and i talked to the
other crew member dan jones actually led
our mission there i was flying his wing
he shared what he recalled another one
of our pilots forest snyder
shared what he recalled but to get full
detail i think was forrest recommended
to me he says hey you need to get a hold
of the american advisor who was on the
ground with that airborne battalion and
and get some information from him
so i tracked down the advisor john duffy
i got a hold of john i hadn't spoken to
him since the war and now this is
however many decades later and said
essentially you know john i uh great to
make contact with you uh and he was
enthused that we made contact with him
and as you see we may bring out the
discussion later
our mission that night that he was
overrun that you read that part
we showed up in the nick of time to save
the day so he credits uh myself and dan
jones who is flying lead with saving his
life as does levan may
so he shared the information that i
needed to get that battle correct for
the few paragraphs i had in the first
book
but as i talked to him over i must have
talked to him a half a dozen times
getting that material
over different days he started dropping
a hint uh that you know that that was
just a really intense battle it was
probably one of the most intense battles
in the vietnam war and i had no idea
that only 37 guys had survived out of a
471 man
battalion plus a few other stragglers
which later later showed up uh later on
so he started dropping his hands hey
it's you know somebody ought to write
the history of that battle and then he
found and knew that i had a phd and
retired colonel and had written that
book and so finally i said john okay
i'll write i'll write it up
what i was thinking at the time is
you know i'll take care of john i'll
write this maybe a 20-page monograph
i'll get the facts down and i'll be done
with it
but as i started talking to him in more
detail and got to meet levan may and
talk to him others involved in the
battle i i soon saw that there was
really a substantial story there that
needed to be told
and rather than a 20 page monograph that
i would crank out in two to three weeks
i spent four years
researching and writing this book
to get it done and i'm very glad that i
did i i know that it is a story that
needed to be shared
and
and also it it
shines a new light on vietnamese forces
vietnamese forces during the war and
since the war have gotten generally bad
press on how they performed in combat
most of that was well deserved a lot of
vietnamese units
though they had some well-intended
soldiers
they did not have good leadership
corrupt leadership and competent
leadership and their story after story
of vietnamese units not fighting well uh
retreating in the face of the enemy
but what i found in researching this
book extraordinary valor is that was not
at all the case with their elite forces
their marines their rangers and most
especially their paratroopers
their airborne units were the the
top top-notch units that fought well
fought with courage
and
as i did my research i confirmed that
and that is the story that i tell in
this book
the book follows the life of the
american advisor it follows the life of
leyvan may who ends up assuming command
of the unit after the commander is
killed and there are the two big heroes
of the book is their story leading up to
the battle and and that was how i came
to write the book and why i wrote the
book and i think the important message
that comes out of the book is the
vietnamese airborne
they call themselves were known in
vietnam as the mudo
the red hats the angels from the sky
fought very very very well and just
about every single
combat they're involved in and most
especially the 11th arvin airborne
battalion on charlie hill was
extraordinary followers
in in reading your book
you start to realize the the way that
the that this unit was held up and this
battle was held up almost like the
battle of thermopylae with the 300
spartans that died to a man trying to
protect the city it's like the same
thing happened here they were trying to
hold this hill
and there's songs about it in the lore
of the vietnamese at the time this was
this this unit was like the 300 spartans
is that a safe assessment yeah it is
that that battle became a landmark in in
vietnamese history
the commander as i said was killed he
became a national hero was promoted
posthumously to colonel they had banners
to him all over saigon and parades in
his honor
there
is a book written about the the battle i
think it's something like the red flames
of summer and then there was a song that
was written about the battle
that is still played at some vietnamese
gatherings that get together and and
we'll we'll play that song about charlie
hill
the other interesting thing i found is
there's recordings of you guys in the
air there's there's i listen i listen to
at least probably 40 minutes
of these call for fires and just like i
was i was a radio man so i wasn't
surprised when this happened but you can
hear the aircraft really well right and
you can barely hear duffy he's all
broken but but man it's amazing to
listen to
this stuff happening
these recordings are incredible they are
and that uh that that recording in
particular was part of the additional
evidence uh and we may get into duffy's
award situation here later and i'll have
more comment on that uh but that
recording surfaced late just just
several years ago
two of my principal sources to be sure
that my information was correct were
you know hard copy or hard vocal sources
that couldn't be disputed one was that
recording that recording was made uh by
one of the helicopter crew members that
went in and picked up the survivors of
that battle the next morning uh after
they were overrun on the hill that night
and so yes we have audio
word for word conversations between all
those helicopters and duffy talking on
he had his prick 77 radio shot off his
back
he had two aircraft survival radios
with him as well so he's talking on one
of those survival radios on on the
emergency push
to those helicopter crews so we had that
recording
also john duffy during the battle
kept a log
of a journal of everything that happened
every day and call signs and coordinates
and and all that so those two things
together help give me the factual
information or confirm factual
information for the book
uh as well as and i'll add this comment
now uh if you want to get an emotional
feel for john duffy and an emotional
feel for this book duffy uh turned out
to be a poet after the war and he has a
website uh epoetryworld.com
john duffy if you google that you'll get
to it but yeah all of this is captured
the emotion of it in in poems that he
has written over the years since yeah
and the title of one of those books is
is the battle for charlie and it's a
book of poems and it's chronological
accounting of what happened really cool
to read
and
i mean i've got some of that that we'll
read during this um that i highlighted
but
yeah definitely an interesting guy that
had a had a cool viewpoint on the world
he's a fascinating guy
um with that let's let's get into the
book a little bit and the book like you
already said it staged around the two
main leaders in this event or who ended
up being the main surviving leaders in
this event
lay van may and major john duffy
so you start off
and again look go buy the book because
the details that you've got in there are
incredible to read i'm going to kind of
give some highlights so people know what
we're dealing with so lay van may was
born in 1942
he's the second of nine children
his father was a farmer uh but i guess
they raised buffalo that's what they did
for a living they had but they raised
crops but they had the two buffalo to to
yeah do whatever you do plow the fields
and then yeah okay got it so the buffalo
were more like the tractors yes exactly
so they were regular farmers
um he was a studious kid hardworking and
he ends up getting accepted into the
vietnamese national military academy
interestingly graduates the same day
that kennedy was assassinated november
22 1963.
uh and he had you know he he kind of
talked about the fact that
he looked at kennedy as this great man
and this was you know somebody that he
saw as a beacon of freedom and all this
he gets commissioned as a second
lieutenant and he asks
for
immediate combat assignment right um
and with that well when you're in
vietnam i guess it doesn't take that
long if you want to go to combat
to get in it i'm going to go to the book
here real quick
uh he's a platoon leader at this point
contact heavy enemy fire stopped their
advance the radio cracked with a call
from the adjacent platoon one two one
two this is one three over
may grabbed the handset from his radio
operator one three this is one two over
one two we are pinned down here heavy
fire lots of vc maybe a company roger
one three i'll try and advance and
relieve pressure on you may's soldiers
stopped in their tracks he needed them
to advance across an open expanse his
greatest anxiety in pondering his role
in combat was not fear for his life but
rather whether his soldiers would follow
his orders
he knew what was expected of him he
worried he might not be able to deliver
he spied two soldiers nearby whom he
felt could be key to his budding plan
one carried a 30 caliber browning
automatic rifle known affectionately as
the bar
the other held a 45 caliber thompson
submachine gun both designs dated to
world war one may boasted a more modern
weapon an m1 grand carbine that had seen
service in world war ii come with me he
called to the pair stay close
may turn to the platoon raised his arm
and shouted follow me
they moved forward arcing to the left
circling the enemy's right side may
stayed in the lead firing his carbine
his two-man assault force made good use
of their automatic weapons the rest of
the platoon moved to keep up placing
effective fire as they advanced they
took casualties individuals fell wounded
some crying in pain
still his soldiers fired and maneuvered
behind his lead until he got them into a
position to attack directly into the
enemy's flank
may led the onslaught insurgents fell
dead dying and wounded
they broke
they ran
the second platoon pursued until may
called them back to consolidate on the
position they just overrun
he congratulated them on their victory
they looked at him with the respect and
admiration he had earned
may exhibited extraordinary leadership
on that first mission
within days the army promoted him to
first lieutenant and placed him in
command of the first company and he
routinely led company in battalion
operations
the actions set his reputation as a
respected combat leader
earning that he's earning that rank
yeah he is you know this reminds me of
something to keep in mind too that we
lose sight of americans went to vietnam
for one year deployments and came home
infantry guys and aviators got to go
two times some three times john duffy
ends up going four times
but those vietnamese we mentioned his
commission date so we're going back to
the early and mid-60s and those
vietnamese were fighting day after day
year after year throughout that whole
war as we would do our rotations uh i i
can only guess i've not even asked may i
should if you know what was your
attitude looking at these american
advisors that would come in for a year
or less at a time and rotate and rotate
out
and see if they've got all the answers
for you telling you what to do and to
how to fight a war
well that's i think one of the
complaints or about that rotational
system is guys come in
by the time they feel comfortable with
what they're doing it's almost time for
them to leave again and i know they did
that a lot with company and battalion
leadership where a leader would come in
and serve three four maybe five months
as a battalion commander as a company
commander and then they'd rotate him out
yep
just when you start to get comfortable
with what's going on you're out of there
and then soon after that you're going
back to the states
whereas world war ii you were going to
deploy until we won
which is a definitely a different way to
do it now that being said
it's
it's at least a little bit nice when you
go to maybe run some combat operations
in the morning and then that afternoon
you go home and have dinner with your
wife right
and that's exactly what happened with uh
with with may he ended up he he met this
this woman um her name was sen
and
you know like he starts having a
relationship
but when he goes to work in the morning
he's going into combat
so that's a little different too yeah
yeah it is and as i mentioned in the
book the vietnamese airborne was the
strategic reserve for
vietnam forces controlled by the general
staff
their locations were all around saigon
uh with one of the units down at wang
tao which was not that far from saigon
so when they weren't deployed off on an
operation yeah may was going home every
night and being with his family
and then they'd usually deploy the air
but the airborne would get deployed if
there was some horrible situation they'd
go up and and save the day uh spend
usually just a few days or the most
couple two or three weeks and then back
to back to saigon back with his family
you know you've got a section in the end
of the book that you talk about where
this these airborne units these
vietnamese airborne units the history of
them and where they came from right can
you talk us through that really quick
because it's pretty interesting the way
they they were originally formed and
where they're rooted yeah i wanted to
include that in the book because again i
i was really impressed when i did my
research and found out the courage and
and valor of the vietnamese airborne
consistently throughout their history
um yeah without giving you're talking to
a phd historian here so i don't want to
go off on an hour and a half lecture on
the vietnamese airborne but
the concise version is
it all began with the french
vietnam was a colony of france's since
the late 1800s
during world war ii the japanese
invaded and took over
vietnam
we the americans worked with the
vietnamese insurgents fighting against
the japanese during the war there's a
whole another story there that i won't
get into but anyway after the war
the french came back trying to
re-establish their colony in vietnam
the vietnamese
a portion of the vietnamese under ho chi
minh
had a
militant arm called the viet minh and
they very much saw themselves as an
independent country and weren't going to
stand for the french coming in to to
take them over
so we have a conflict between the french
and the viet minh after the war uh the
french had
vietnamese that didn't want anything to
do with the communists that ends up
becoming south vietnam
but as the french tried to reassert
themselves looking to the
i want to say friendly vietnamese but
those who are aligned with the french
they
the french
had airborne units came to vietnam they
saw some advantage to getting vietnamese
military to be part of that airborne and
that's where the whole thing started
they started training indigenous
vietnamese to become paratroopers
those vietnamese were trained and molded
on the french model
in time there were vietnamese airborne
companies that would fight as a part of
french battalions
in time by the time we get to the the
nbn foo battle which is going to be the
undoing of the french and vietnam in
indochina in 1954
there are vietnamese airborne battalions
by that time fighting so that was the
start of the vietnamese airborne it
started on the french model uh there and
so they still to the u.s involvement in
the war tracked their origins to the to
the french
and and kept that same proud model the
red berets that they wore
came from the french
and that's what that's what may ends up
volunteering for you know after he spent
some time in the in the infantry he he
then
volunteers for this elite vietnamese
airborne division
and you've got a bunch of uh
good combat stories in there what did
you spend a lot of time talking to me
retracing this stuff huh
i yeah over a period of four years i
talked to may i don't know i should look
at my notes i've got about 10 interviews
with may
i probably got 18 interviews with duffy
uh half half a dozen interviews with
with high who we'll might talk about in
a little bit but he ended up being the
operations officer of the 11th battalion
maze the executive officer
colonel bow is the commander who gets
killed in in the battle so i spent a lot
of time talking to to those guys
principally may high and duffy uh at one
time i even
flew down to san jose went to santa cruz
where duffy lives and may and high came
down and we spent an entire day
sitting around duffy's dining room table
i had blown up some maps i forgot i
think i had one to
i don't know 25 000 or something that i
blew up into huge maps we laid on the
table we went over that battle in great
detail so yes i've spent a lot of time
with all of those guys to get this right
next time you do that can you tell me so
i can come and watch and maybe even
bring echo so you can press record oh
gosh that's phenomenal i know we talked
about maybe getting some of these guys
on in the future that'd be awesome
um
he he he ends up getting married did you
record did you record these
interactions that you had before you go
i did well every single interview i did
on the phone i recorded and i have those
recordings and that entire session we
spent that day i recorded the whole day
yes
oh there's going to be some requests for
that
yeah i don't i think when i did those
recordings it was with their
understanding that we were doing those
in confidence that that would not be
released to the world
uh
um
he so he gets married to sen
this woman that he had met
he
is enjoying life he's
um he's got his comrades you've got
you've got a section in there they drink
this
this martel cognac
which is a very superior old pale that's
what's written on the bottle vsop yeah
vsop vsop is on the bottle and and the
paratroopers they say that it doesn't
stand for very superior old pale it
stands for very sexy old paratroopers
that's a fact
so there's some good uh
some good camaraderie with these guys
yep and and again it's just wild to
think that these guys are working
they're living at home they're with
their family and then they go on
deployment for two or three weeks
and do heroic stuff and then go back and
get back with their family
it's a whole it's a whole different kind
of war fighting than i i mean
yeah i guess you could say the civil war
we did that in america but
i mean other than that we've been
fighting in other countries yeah we
haven't had that just go home to your
family at the end of a day of combat
well most vietnamese units didn't this
was the luxury of the airborne but they
you know they did more risk than anybody
else and you mentioned them getting
married they got married uh during the
tet or just at the end of the ted
offensive
and may had gotten deployed up to uh to
way city during the during the ted
offensive
and fought in his i think he was
commanding a company then
they got down to 25 combat strength were
no longer combat effective so got sent
back to saigon to re-outfit and refit
get dec ready for the next deployment
and it was on that break and after
losing so much of your of your unit and
and all those casualties uh sen and may
decided hey if we can't wait any longer
we need to get married so that's when
they got married
uh yeah you've got a bunch of those
details in here obviously we're not
reading the whole book go buy the book
and and get the rest of that story um
let's look at john duffy okay the other
major character here i'm gonna go to the
book
because i like this intro there is no
question where john duffy is from he was
born in manhattan moved to queens at a
young age and then brooklyn he never
lost his accent or the peppering of
profanities he picked up in the public
schools and on the streets of the city
world war ii raged during his early
years he was seven years old when it
ended he remembered it well and then you
kind of you go through some of these
this is so much this just like a it
should be a movie this whole section
about him growing up
in in and around the boroughs in new
york you know he's like a smart kid but
he thinks school is boring he's really
good at math but he's skipping school
the whole nine yards cut in class
uh just a rebellious kid
sounds familiar actually in some forms
uh and then
uh going back to the book when he was 16
a neighbor a paratrooper in the 107
187th airborne regimental combat team
visited the family he just returned from
the korean war the ward ended some
months earlier but the soldier was just
now being sent home he stood in the
family's living room his uniform sharp
his pants tucked into his tall shined
leather boots john was impressed the
stories of war impressed him the
immaculate uniform with its badges and
medals impressed him but the shiny boots
impressed jon the most the boots that
only paratroopers could wear with their
class a service uniform those highly
polished brown jump boots caught his eye
and his imagination in that instant john
was hooked yes paratrooper that's what i
want to be
as soon as he turned 17 he got his
parents permission to enlist he entered
the army as a private two days after his
birthday before finishing his junior
year of high school get some
he breezed through basic and infantry
training airborne school at fort
campbell kentucky proved more of a
challenge john endured the verbal abuse
and the physical pain gutting it out
until he earned his coveted jump wings
at 17 and a half the army assigned him
immediately to the 11th airborne
division in germany
so
that's that's just that's john duffy
that's that's a pretty cool way to kick
things off but but what's interesting
and you go into this in the book
like his first tour is not that big of a
deal it's in between the korean war and
the vietnam war there's not a lot going
on
he does his tour
he decides he's gonna get out he comes
home he tries a couple of different
things one of them was dan what a
dancing instructor
he did not know anything about dancing
he was home he was out of the army he
was driving around there's all kinds of
stories what he's doing driving around
and he passes this arthur murray dance
studio and it says dance instructor
wanted i think is the window hiring and
so he walks in and applies for the job
and has to stamp around and learn learn
how to dance so he can be a dance
instructor but he turned into a very
good dancing instructor and yeah he
still maintains some of that suave
suave nature if i can tell a little side
story
we had many years ago in san diego a
vietnam helicopter pilots reunion i
forget how it was a long long time ago
john duffy showed up just because he was
in town visiting his brother and he
heard about the reunion and and he
showed up and i that's the first time i
ever met him face to face and saw him
uh i had my young daughter with me i
think she was i don't know 13 years old
if that and my wife
one of the events for the reunion was a
a social thing on the midway up on the
deck and they had a band up there with
dancing so he gets my young daughter and
starts dancing with her on the deck of
the midway uh hearkening back to his
arthur murray dance instructor and it
was beautiful and she loved it
um
okay fast forward and i don't want to
get too far forward because we'll come
to this i'm sure but we were at the
white house
just a week ago and uh and he had just
gotten his medal uh pinned around his
neck and we were in a social in the i
don't know with the ceremonies in the
east room one of the other rooms there
and he got chelsea and twirled her
around like dancing moves up there so it
was really really nice and harken back
to that old-time memory which is just a
little further detail on his dance
prowess that he got by stepping into an
arthur murray studio knowing nothing
about dancing and saying i'd like that
job and there he goes what year was the
reunion here in san diego oh i'd have to
look i don't know it was i mean if your
daughter was 13. then it was like
13 years she's 27 now so
14 years ago
then he still got the moves he still had
the moves and he still has his brooklyn
accent to this day
uh
well
following his story where it goes from
there um after his dance
he i guess he didn't love it too much
because he decided he was going to go
make his fortune as a gambler yeah now
he played cards as a kid that's earlier
in the book too so he really thought he
had the the the stuff he needed to be a
winner at card games in las vegas yeah
go ahead so he so he packs up his car
and goes to vegas to go and you know i
mean clearly just make a fortune in
vegas you know this is a pretty common
idea you know these people are giving
away money out there
well uh what two or three months into it
he's completely broke and he has to sell
his car doesn't even have his car
anymore he's on foot
next stop army recruiter
so he goes back into the army um
and when he goes back in the army still
you know there's there's no war going on
or anything um becomes a finance clerk
gets sent to munich
uh meets a german woman
you know and then he got orders to tenth
special forces group and he's assigned
to an a team now when he did that
i tried to figure out did was was there
any school that he was required to go to
or how did that work no there was you
know like today to get into special
forces and certainly navy seals i mean
you got to go yeah you got to pass buds
for this right and and army special
forces you have to go through a school
and a lot of guys get weeded out no then
he he was parachute qualified uh and had
some jumps that his first tour in europe
was with the airborne division so he's
in munich as i remember doing some uh
clerical nothing job wanted to get out
of there and so he volunteered to go
down to bad tolts
with the special forces down there and
he had before he could wear a beret he
had to go through qualification in a
whole bunch of just local schools
but it was nothing like what they have
today and once he uh gained certain
qualifications then he was able to get
to get his badge and work for his prey
yeah that's
that was pretty awesome to read through
that um
so he's he becomes a demolition guy at
uh at at an a team
he gets recommended for ocs
and then he he breaks his arm three what
is it two three times three times the
same arm
keeps breaking his arm
um
eventually he he
heals up his arm he goes to ocs he
graduates september 11th 1963. he's now
got two kids
once he graduates from ocs
um he gets assigned to the 801st
military intelligence detachment at fort
bragg
he's not loving this no
and and this is back when if you were in
special forces
or in like any special operations you
that wasn't a good career move
you know it's not like now where it can
be very good for your career if you're
in the army or if you're in the navy if
you're in special operations it can be
back in these days it was not good for
your career and the officers that were
looking out for you would actually say
hey you don't want to keep doing this
special operation stuff that's not
that's not going to get you anywhere
so they gave him this other assignment
he can't stand it right
and eventually he's
he's wants to go to
vietnam and he gets orders
back to special forces and he gets
assigned to fifth special forces in
vietnam he sent to caisson
and then he sent to uh to
what is it
long bay long vey gets sent to long bay
where he's going to be
working with the mountain yards the the
the brew tribesmen
and this is where he gets his first
combat so he's actually been in the army
for a long time yes
and he but this is where he gets his
first combat and since we we covered
may's first combat let's jump on
let's jump on duffy's first combat going
back to the book
the choppers hovered a few feet above
the ground
the brew fighters and their special
forces advisors jumped off the
helicopters climbed quickly departing to
the east the rotor noise faded all stood
in silence duffy stayed close to the
brew commander
they moved off the landing zone and set
out they scoured the immediate area
before beginning a three-day sweep
northward
back to their camp at lang bay
they had no encounters the first day but
the next morning they walked into a viet
cong ambush rat a tat tat and enemy fire
the brew militia leaders shouted orders
the commander turned to duffy pointing
to his left front vc 10 o'clock maybe
platoon maybe more
the indige force spread out and returned
fire the noise of the firefight
intensified bullets zipped past jon men
dropped wounded others fell dead a hand
grenade landed nearby shrapnel tearing
into duffy's left knee a wound that
would reward him his first purple heart
another grenade rolled between his feet
he held his breath oh christ i'm dead
it didn't detonate
his heart pounded he took a moment to
bandage his wounded knee then a calm
settled over him he began to
methodically appraise the situation to
try and make sense of what the enemy was
doing to consider the tactics of his
fighters to assess the project of the
progress of the battle
he turned to the brew commander and
firmly directed counter-attack
counter-attack now
in the face of the brew advance the viet
cong withdrew dragging their wounded
with them duffy's voice followed the
blood
duffy's force followed the blood trail
for a while
but their foe had escaped they resumed
the sweep northward
no further enemy contact
john duffy had seen his first combat
he'd reacted as he hoped he would done
what he was trained to do kept his wits
about him
he reflected scary but better than
expected
this is my destiny
so there's his first combat
situation that he goes into
gets wounded gets hit with a grenade
has a grenade dud land between his legs
which is a nightmare
and he knows that he is a lucky man that
that was his first purple heart he has
eight purple hearts
go all the way up through uh through
firebase charlie yeah
um this was this was another um
situation that you talk about in the
book that definitely
needs to be covered here
it says on march 2nd
1967 a clear day two silver jets
screamed down route 9 flying low from
the east
many in the special forces camp waved
the jets popped up
turned
and dropped bombs on lang bay village
with some hitting the special forces
camp radio calls went out in vain
no contact with the jets they returned
for another pass this time with 20
millimeter cannons blazing the camp
opened fire thinking the jets are
hostile they weren't they were american
they'd made a mistake
it was possibly the worst friendly fire
incident of the war killing 112 brew
villagers and wounding 213.
duffy's green berets entered the village
the devastation appalled them they
dashed through frame flames and still
exploding ordinance to pull injured
families from burning structures risking
his life time and time again duffy
rescued survivors many still hid in
underground bunkers john and his men
crawled into several begging the
occupants to leave some did others
didn't they were so terrorized that they
were frozen in place
john went for the village chief
when they returned to the first bunker
it was too late everyone had died the
flames that smoke had made the air
unbreathable
the americans treated the wounded while
the villagers retrieved their dead team
members soon used up most of their
medical supplies
when proper sutures ran out they turned
to safety pins
the team helped buried the dead and
arranged for medical evacuation of the
wounded duffy requested help through
channels to make amends as much as that
might be possible emergency flights
brought food medicine clothing and
building materials u.s navy seabees
construction engineers showed up with a
backhoe together the tribesmen green
berets and seabees built a new lang
langvae village a short distance from
the old one the brood chief demanded the
old village site be abandoned
his claim he claimed his people saw it
as infested with evil spirits because
the terrible fate that had befallen it
duffy leveraged circumstances to also
have an airstrip built adjacent to the
special forces camp
john had commanded
a101 at lang bay for a little over three
months when he received orders to be the
executive officer for a113
the much larger special forces mobile
strike force for all of i-corps the
northernmost tactical region of south
vietnam they called it mike force mike
being shortened term for mobile strike
so that was a horrible scenario it was
and that remains a nightmare in john's
mind to this day
he did what he could do but yeah it was
the the jets and i honestly don't
remember now if they were air force navy
or marine but
the jets thought that that was an enemy
village and i think they thought it was
just across the laotian border
but it wasn't it was long bay camp uh
and uh yeah it was uh it was terrible
uh john was the commander of that
special forces detachment a101
long bay uh would later get and he may
get into one of them but got overrun
twice
the second time was
gosh when
1967 i think
and there was a book written about that
called night of the silver stars
and so many of those guys got killed
captured a few were rescued
i ended up in prison camp with
two three guys i think from from the
long bay camp that were captured that
second time it was it was overrun
um
you
you go into some of the stuff in the
book um
of what took place during the rest of
that deployment and then his tour of
duty ends that first tour of duty
ends january 17 1968 just before the
1968 ted offensive right
um
he gets home
he you know like oftentimes happens he
gets home his his family uh
his family reunion getting back together
with his family wasn't wasn't exactly
what it should have been ends up getting
divorced
um
and he you know is ready to go back to
vietnam
and he he ends up going back to vietnam
he gets assigned to the phoenix program
yes and
we've had uh people from the phoenix
program on on this podcast before the
phoenix program was essentially an
assassination program to kill
senior
viet cong leadership
and just assassinate them
it didn't seem like john liked that idea
very much he did not like it at all
uh he he claimed two things one he said
his vietnamese language capability
wasn't good enough
but that was just an excuse i think he
he didn't want anything to do with uh
with phoenix he set his sights other
places
and so he he
pretty much just
had her had he had heard about sog at
this point
yeah he had heard about sag and largely
i mean he commanded a101 suspect special
forces experience uh and and sog
missions going into laos from from
vietnam he was aware of it
so he just got grabbed his records and
and headed to uh sog headquarters in
saigon to make his case
uh
shows up there shows up at the sag
headquarters
and uh
and sog i might say is uh
they they the the special operations
were run and saw i thought they they had
a
little covert deal here because sag
stood for and the sign on the street out
in front of the building was studies and
observations group it was kind of an
innocuous means nothing deal and who
would know and who would care what went
on there
but in short order their exploits became
excuse me somewhat known
at least that they were doing sneaky
strange stuff probably across the border
so most everybody when they'd hear sog
would think it just special operations
group that's what it was so their
studies and observations uh group didn't
didn't carry it too well but yeah so
john found his way to their headquarters
building which was just a
building on a street in saigon it wasn't
on a on a military base at all and yeah
went in to make his case that he didn't
want to have anything to do with phoenix
and could they help him
uh
colonel eiler who's one of the saag
commanders um
he says sat down behind his desk and
read through john's military records
they chatted for a while the colonel
made a phone call he leaned back in his
chair and said you're no longer assigned
to the phoenix program you're now a
member of sog welcome aboard
i want you to cut off all the insignia
from your uniforms and report back here
at zero 700 tomorrow morning with all
your stuff duffy responded with a loud
yes sir
uh he gets an in brief
we run mac v sog missions onto the trail
same as the launch sites in south
vietnam but we are weather backup when
things are too skoshed on that side we
insert
and recover teams from here sog teams
out of vietnam are normally three u.s
and eight to ten indigenous
most that we work with are two u.s and
four indige because the helicopter
limitations john asked what exactly do
we do
mostly reconnaissance behind enemy lines
watching the trail gathering intel and
sometimes directing airstrikes on enemy
convoys or fuel and supply depots
they'll tap into communications lines
when they find them they also conduct
ground raids to destroy supplies and
equipment they'll mine roads on occasion
and snatch prisoners too
he looked right at john all highly
classified we don't exist we're not here
his expression tightened it's dicey
we've lost a number of teams
he turned and motioned to john let's go
meet the commander and get you settled
in major bill shelton the mlt-3
commander made captain duffy his
executive officer overseeing operations
and intelligence activities at the same
time duffy functioned as a launch
officer responsible for coordinating
individual sog team missions he also
routinely flew in the ov-10 broncos as a
backseat sog observer the front seat us
air force pilots were all qualified for
forward error controllers or facts the
aircraft provided an immediate available
overhead capability to synchronize
support in real time
as t as a team conducted its assigned
mission deep in enemy held territory
so
yeah we've had a quite a few sog guys on
here so he's up basically flying covey
right yeah they called the uh the guys
that flew in the aircraft cubby riders
they were sog qualified guys special
forces guys could really appreciate
relate to the mission
and from the air they would coordinate
all support
as that said the front seat air force
pilot of the ov10 was qualified as a
fact forward air controller uh but in
time the backseat covey riders could do
as much adjustment of uh air as that
front seat
i might comment where there was a time a
few years ago where i couldn't put those
sentences in that book it was still
sensitive highly classified information
uh thanks goes to another
former saw guy who wrote some books and
the first book i think that really got
this information out in the open his
name is john plaster and he wrote a book
called sog america's secret commandos
and and he coordinated and cleared to
get that information out but until then
even the involvement i had in my mission
before i was shot down and captured
supporting song i couldn't people say
what'd you do in the great vietnam war
as well through helicopters and gunships
and that's about all i can i can talk
about so john plaster got this all out
in the open so we could uh give that
level of detail of what what john duffy
was was doing
and i don't know if we mentioned mobile
launch team three was out in
non-conference thailand
so this part of saag was on the west
side of laos most of their operations
ran from forward operating bases or fobs
inside of vietnam there were three of
them that would launch the teams into
laos and recover
back into vietnam but if the weather was
skoshed then all the weight went on
mobile launch team three and
non-confederm to come in from the
thailand side
yeah it's crazy uh i i think it was a
20-year waiting period that they had on
the sog mission so nothing was said
about it until
like 1995 or 1994. before anyone even
broached the subject right you know
we've had john striker meyer on here a
few times i know he wrote a couple
articles early
for like soldier of fortune magazine or
something and
started you know getting the word out
about the
insane
uh and heroic operations that the guys
at sog did
yeah just
crazy so john duffy was flying covey
writer on that second tour of duty in
addition to being the launch officer and
all the other admin responsibilities in
the unit but he spent a lot of time in
ov-10s out over the trail uh according
to those guys on or supporting those
guys on the ground yeah and he clearly
which we'll see i mean he got extremely
good at understanding how to utilize air
support yup no doubt about it
uh he received five air medals for valor
during the missions he flew there
following a year of challenging and
rewarding service his second combat tour
ended he got orders back to the united
states so that ends john duffy's tour
meanwhile
uh
may levon may is also continuing to get
more and more
combat experience
especially now where after tet of 1968
he fought in khaeson he fought in the
aysha valley
he was in the field fighting when he got
radio traffic that he was
that he had a son
he was part of
lam sawn 719 the largest helicopter
assault the war
which we covered on podcasts uh 294 with
a huey pilot
jay tate
and
what what
van may did on that he was held on held
in reserve so he there was a bunch of a
bunch of vietnamese troops that went in
into cambodia and he was in reserve his
unit was in reserve so they didn't go in
and into laos uh
719. and yeah he was part of the
second brigade and they were supposed to
be the final and they were going to do
an
airborne or air mobile assault at the
town of chapon which was the end of this
of this attack into into laos
but for some reason his mission got
changed and he never did that
i think the president of vietnam got a
little bit cold feet and decided to
withdraw earlier than anticipated of
course that withdrawal turned into a
route they had some ground forces in
there some rangers trying to hold
some outposts on on either side of the
advance and that turned into a mess
but yeah may's unit never got deployed
across the border on lomsan 719 was held
in reserve
the only action they saw was when the
vietnamese forces were coming back
across the border they facilitated that
crossing
and meanwhile while that's happening
john duffy he wants to get back to
vietnam of course again
uh he
he can't get orders he's trying to get
orders and finally he volunteers to go
back to sog right
and
he's thinking hey you know what great
i'll go back to sog i'll get some more
combat experience well when he gets back
to sog
he gets told you're too senior for
anything in the field right so you're
basically going to be riding a desk
he doesn't like that he didn't like
being in a combat zone with no combat
it's how you put it in the book right
uh
he spends four months there at sog
headquarters and then he asks to get
reassigned
to
team 162
which was a team that worked directly
with the vietnamese airborne units
and the colonel that's he's asking to go
and get this transfer from
tells him you'll you'll be killed you
you ignorant son of a [__]
exactly and duffy replies so be it
[Music]
john duffy wanted to get back into
combat badly
um
he drives to red hat hill what's the
deal with red hat hill red hat hill is a
are of an army of the republic of
vietnam airborne base uh on the edge of
saigon
north
northeast of the downtown city of saigon
and that was a
it was the base for the 11th airborne
battalion
and a small advisory group
and
they trained there
their barracks were there and it was
from there that they would deploy to
their combat operations and again close
enough mae's family was in saigon so it
was close enough that he could again
drive home
every night and
spend time at home and then go back to
work in the morning
he gets up there where he's going to
become an advisor and the battalion
commander is having a weekly meeting and
i'm going to go to the book for when he
shows up
this weekly meeting is happening
as business wrapped up the six foot
three strapping americans strode through
the door his look intense his movement
deliberate he wore a brand new
camouflage patterned airborne uniform
and the red vietnamese beret
he scanned the room and spotted the
ranking officer colonel bow
he walked over to him the two spoke bow
looked over before turning to the group
this is our new senior advisor major
john duffy he is an american special
forces officer
all eyes were on john
after a somewhat awkward pause bowel
commented or bow continued why don't you
tell us about yourself major duffy john
briefly recounted his previous tours in
vietnam highlighting his combat
experience
on concluding he said i'm very glad to
be here
his sincerity impressed everyone they
all greeted him individually and in
small groups mae just stared for a time
he was taken with the fact that john was
a special that john was special forces
he knew their work along the border and
had heard stories of their covert
operations he'd seen the john wayne
movie at the saigon theater the
soundtrack tuned barry sadler's ballad
of the green berets played in his head
finally he stepped forward in his very
best english he said hello i'm major may
the xl
john looked at him smiled and said in
his best vietnamese i'm major john duffy
i look forward to working with you
may smiled broadly he wanted to learn
all he could from this american
as senior adviser protocol dictated that
john would work principally with the
commander lieutenant colonel bow
normally his contact with the executive
officer may would be minimal the xo was
to pair with an assistant advisor but
from the outset this was no normal
relationship there was no assistant
advisor john was it
personnel shortages dictated filling the
three-man team with only one person
from the outset the strapping american
intrigued may and john duffy saw
something in may that immediately
impressed him
thereafter may took every opportunity to
talk to john during breaks in training
and after unit meetings
may drew from john's green beret
experience while john learned all he
could about arvind procedures and most
importantly getting a better
understanding of vietnamese culture
pretty cool introduction those guys they
kind of hit it off out of the gate yep
right immediately
uh not long after that they start
operating they start doing missions
um going to the book here at dawn on
october 5th 1971 the north vietnamese
attacked in earnest a force of over a
thousand soldiers hit the battalion hard
enemy mortars and rockets pounded them
john woke with a start officers and
sergeants shouted command
bringing a disciplined response to the
madness around them john made his way to
bow high was already there who's high
the operation is the operations officer
the battalion s3 so bow is the commander
hai is the operations officer may ran up
in an instant bao calmly passed orders
through the radio operator
seeing his team assembled he said ground
attack come for sure hi get us vnaf
vietnamese air force
a1 skyraiders
put artillery all around perimeter may
go to companies coordinate counter
attack duffy how about air strikes quick
and real close
bow went on in vietnamese for a moment
providing more detail to his operations
officer and xo
the sound of bugles and whistles and
screams filled the air small arms fire
intensified the ground attack had be had
begun
go bow commanded they each said about
their tasks john moved a short distance
away to a protected spot and got on his
radio attempting to contact american
ford air controller who was airborne in
a small propeller driven spotter plane
any fact any fact this is dusty cyanide
advisor with vietnamese airborne
battalion under attack need air badly
any fact any fact
station calling for fact this is chico
one two roger one two this is dusty
cyanide been receiving heavy incoming
ground attack underway multiple enemy
battalions holding as best we can but
need air understood dusty we'll have
fighters for you shortly what are the
friendly locations and where are the
enemy targets
john passed the details for the strike
to the forward air controller bow
approached as they discussed options for
the battle a rocket blast hit them with
the full fury of a shrapnel fragments
peppered the left side of john's face
and tore into bowels right eye it looked
bad blackened and bloody they wiped
their wounds and continued the fight bow
headed toward the sound of the most
intense fighting duffy looked around and
saw several critically wounded nearby
dismissing his own injuries he left his
protected position exposing himself to
enemy fire so he could render first aid
he saw the battalion
surgeon dr liu is that right lou
dr lou dr lou doing the same his uniform
turned torn and dirty his body bloodied
from his own wounds once the jet
fighters arrived john moved about
wherever necessary to best direct air
strikes remaining calm and focused
oblivious to the bullets flying around
him that day john duffy put in more than
40 flights of fighter aircraft those
airstrikes on top of the courageous
fighting of the paratroopers saved the
battalion from being overrun
may led a successful counter-attack with
one with 114 company in the lead
in the midst of the fray duffy found
time to supervise cutting a landing zone
so that vnaf medevac helicopters could
get in to pick up the wounded the nva
killed 10 11th battalion paratroopers
and wounded 74.
when it was all over duffy
bow
may and high
stood facing each other their uniforms
soiled with dirt and blood their faces
smudged with filth their eyes read from
exhaustion bowel studied his team smiled
and nodded in appreciation
may looked at the intensity on john
duffy's face john returned his glance
softened his expression
and gave his friend a knowing wink
these guys are in it
yeah that was the end of one hellacious
battle for those guys and uh you know
bao's eye injury he lost his eye
in that uh in that battle
would not be medevac continued to fight
with those guys yeah it was
quite something yeah and uh look i
apologize i kind of jumped towards the
end of that battle there's a whole scene
running up to that so
i can't read the whole book exactly when
you want the rest of those details to
get the book
uh
they
you know you you go over more operations
you detail them the bonds between these
guys strengthen they they really become
uh real true comrades
and then i'm gonna fast forward a little
bit
the 11th airborne battalion headed to
khantoum on march 31 1972 conditions
there grew more intense each day
for months intelligence reports had
warned of north vietnamese preparations
for a major attack two cobra gunships
from the u.s army's 361st aerial weapons
company spotted enemy tanks in late
january subsequent sightings by other
american helicopters and the vietnamese
air force followed arvind ground patrols
encountered even larger nva units as the
weeks progressed
prisoners and documents seized in
february confirmed the presence of 10 to
20 000 nva soldiers along with tanks
artillery and large numbers of
anti-aircraft weapons all poised in the
tri-border area of western contour
province
something bad is about to happen
yeah you know it's it's it's interesting
uh this is going to turn into or turn
out to be the 1972 easter offensive this
is march 31st of of
of
year 1972
and nobody had a clue i mean we knew
that the enemy was up to something in
our support of the saud guys out there
they had seen stuff going on uh but it
is all about to come to a uh a crescendo
here in the uh in the central highlands
as well as well the easter offensive
began and i think we'll get to that with
an invasion across the demilitarized
zone in the north into i-corps the
northern area of south vietnam uh out of
cambodia towards saigon trying to thrust
a saigon and then out of laos and
cambodia into canton province into the
central highlands and we're going to
soon find ourselves right in the middle
of the of the largest enemy offensive of
the war
while americans were still there now
most well most people don't know
anything about the vietnam war anyway
but most who know something about the
vietnam war will tell you that the
largest defensive was tet of 68.
that certainly gets the most notoriety
in the spring of 1972 most american
ground forces were gone we were
withdrawing from the war so the eastern
offensive doesn't get quite the
notoriety but it was a significantly
larger enemy operation than the tet
offense of a 68 and this marked a
watershed change the war was no longer a
guerrilla war with the easter offensive
of 72 it was a conventional war north
vietnam sent every division they had
saved one that they kept in the north
every other division came south and it
was regular regular infantry
armor tanks air defense all over the
place
and it was it was something
what did this seem like from your
perspective at the time on the ground
you're well how old are you at this
point 25 something like that 20
yeah by the easter offensive i was 26 i
went to vietnam on my second tour at 25
had a birthday
in late december so i was a
young 26 year old army captain so
obviously
now you know you look back and you see
this big strategic picture what did it
look like
for you on the ground when you're 26
years old and you're a freaking
helicopter gunslinger
yeah well we were just flying missions
you know and the missions up until then
we're supporting the mcb sog operations
and and those were just full of
excitement too because
uh
with the enemy buildup that we were just
beginning to have an appreciation for
those teams most often i don't want to
overstate it but i think i can say most
often
after we put them in their extractions
were a tacky tactical emergency
because they had made contact with the
enemy and the enemy had discovered them
and was in hot pursuit and they were
very exciting extractions with us firing
cobra weapons very very close
for their extraction and even their
missions inside of south vietnam now
which as i said earlier was primarily
what they were what they were doing uh
still the enemy was in growing strength
so every one of their missions was was
pretty dicey
um
yeah so what was i don't know what is it
for a 26 year old i mean you've been
there too as a young young guy off in
combat
yeah you're getting shot at the aircraft
are taking hits
it's it's exciting for the guys on the
ground trying to get them out of there
there's some
there's some fear on the missions i mean
you'd be crazy if you're not afraid when
you're in the middle of combat but
you're doing what you're trained to do
so you focus on that and and you get
through it and for aviators luckily at
the end of the day we get to fly back to
the air base and get out of our
helicopter and go to our little officers
club and start throwing down throwing
down some drinks to get ready to do the
same thing the next day
we didn't really appreciate what this
buildup signified we were seeing more
action we're seeing more enemy activity
and and so we shifted from support for
the mcp sock guys out of fob two
uh to just kind of a gentle fire brigade
in the central highlands and so it was
turning into every day we'd launch in
the morning really not knowing exactly
what was happening but we get calls for
support and we go provide
gun support rearm refuel go back out and
spend the days doing that
i guess there was some level of worry
even for a 26 year old that started to
mount
because then we started having aircraft
shot down we had a oh 58 shot down and
the pilot was missing in action assumed
captured and so there was all that to be
concerned about
but that comes back to the attitude that
young people have i realized that things
were happening that things were building
up that people were getting hurt and
aircraft were getting going down
but i never for a minute
thought that any of that would happen to
me because there's something in our mind
in our in our psych particularly for
combat guys that hey you know stuff bad
stuff happens but it's happening to
someone else it's uh it's not going to
happen to me and that's how you
strap into the helicopter every day and
go back out and do the do the same thing
again now
now you got shot down your first
deployment i did to vietnam i did and
you survived obviously and you evaded
the enemy and you got picked up do you
think that bolstered your confidence
yeah
i don't know i don't want to talk too
much about my own psychology because
i've had you know after i get back to
being a prisoner we had to have
psychological evaluations and stuff and
and the psychiatrists say well you know
what are some of the things you enjoy
well you know i was a forest firefighter
and i enjoyed that and i did a little
college road some rodeo and and i like
to ride motorcycles and then the guy oh
okay
would you have a death no i don't have a
death wish i guess so yeah i i don't
know there's something about
psychological makeup of some people uh
that they do okay in in that type of
situation
uh and you know that would come all the
way to how i've adjusted since i got
back from vietnam and i go into a lot of
that in my first
book of
the
trials and tribulations that i faced and
what today would be called ptsd but
you know i got through all of that and i
tell some of the ways that i did that
and i think i'm
semi fine today
so you know whatever whatever mental
mindset got me through those combat
operations on that second tour also got
me through first tour i was shot down
over the middle of laos i had injuries
to my neck i
rode an ejection seat out a very short
parachute ride down we were crashing
through the trees by the time i punched
out so i got a partial shoot deployment
night and i hit the ground
but as soon and i got picked up and
taken to hospital in thailand and was in
the hospital for a while and then back
to the unit and and as soon as i go back
to the unit i was up reporting to the
flight surgeon to say hey i got to get
back on flight status i got to go fly
so
yeah who knows what's there but i i was
enthusiastic
to fly my missions on the first tour and
after uh a break back to the states and
back to vietnam i had to fight because
u.s was withdrawing so rapidly i had to
fight at every level to get assigned to
a unit still in combat um yeah so maybe
there's a little duffy inside of me i
don't i don't know i wanted to get back
into the fight
now as you're seeing this massive
build-up i mean you're seeing tanks on
the ground right
this has got to change your viewpoint a
little bit it seems like everyone would
say oh something massive is coming yeah
the massive wasn't there for summer
something's coming uh
i think somewhere in the back of my mind
was well whatever it is we'll handle it
you know if the enemy comes out of the
woods we've got b-52s and all these air
strikes and we'll just annihilate them
in place similar to what was done up at
caisson
in
when they put case on under seas we just
and really caused the enemy a lot of
damage so i think that thought was there
um
yeah there must have been some concern
because some of the attacks the enemy
attacked
route 19 which was between our base at
plateku and the coast and they closed
route 19 we got involved in a bunch of
operations down there so we were cut off
in the highlands there was no road
transport coming to our base at camp
holloway near pleiku all our supplies
had to come in at c130s on the runway
engineer crews came in there to improve
the psp runway and make it better
there was some talk that that was done
because if the situation got bad enough
they'd have to get in and extract us and
get us out of there
i don't know somehow that just we still
had our routine of daily go fly combat
missions and come home at night and get
drunk and get up the next morning and go
do it all again how long would you fly
for in the day
oh
gosh um
i don't know four or five six hours but
the day was longer because we would
take off in the morning and if we didn't
have a mission right away we'd go stand
by somewhere at
docto
or uh
or at the fob pad the the the sog pad
so there was a lot of down time waiting
just waiting would you wait in your bird
yeah well we'd wait next not sitting in
the bird next to the bird sometimes we
play a little cards
but we'd be right there so we could
launch within within two minutes that
was our routine when we put the sog
teams in too we put the team in we go
back to usually docto and we just sit
there and wait because if the team got
in trouble we had to be immediately
available for them
so yeah on any given day there was some
down time just sitting waiting for lunch
once the activity started picking up in
the easter offensive though it was
a lot of flying refueling flying
refueling that if you recall in my first
book by the time we got there now this
is going to be three weeks after the
charlie battle
boy it was all day i mean i did three
rotations into combat before noon it was
on my third rotation into combat that i
got shot down and that was
before before we got to noon
man
yeah that's uh that's wild how it how it
all looks in
in in retrospect right what this looks
like now
as you're looking back you think man
they had all these tanks they're they're
moving in there's thousands and
thousands of troops massing
uh it looks crazy now i mean i think
about here i am a 76 year old
and
wow who would do that's nuts yeah
and you also wonder like what what are
you hearing anything from like the
strategic leadership you know like hey
this is going to be a big event and
here's was there any kind of
adjustment to the grand strategy or
anything
well there was as i found out doing
right but no at the time on the ground
no we didn't know anything about
strategic leadership we're just a bunch
of young guys flying cobras going where
we were needed and shooting shooting up
a storm
all right
so
as this is going on i'm going to fast
forward in the book a little bit to a
brigade briefing situation
uh it says the brigade staff briefed the
situation it was not good each delivered
remarks in english and this is the
vietnamese airborne brigade each each
delivered remarks in english followed by
detailed explanation of vietnamese to
ensure full understanding by all the
presentations emphasized
that enemy numbers increase daily
flowing in from sanctuaries across the
border in laos and cambodia the tempo of
nva operations inside south vietnam had
picked up they shelled military outposts
and even major installations
that included the vital airfield in
contour city
the north vietnamese brought large
numbers of anti-aircraft machine guns
with them and shot at every aircraft in
range
they appeared to be on the cusp of
something big colonel leak leak
uh lick colonel colonel lick
stood up to give his personal appraisal
in english
the enemy will come from laos on route
and move east to tan khan
they come from cambodia on new road they
build a long old french route
that set up attack on quantum city both
from west and north
once take con tomb they move to placo
then turn east and attack through on k
to coast they cut our country in half
just like they do to beat french in
1954.
john looked questionably at may i'll
tell you more about that later may
whispered
he looks squarely up he looks squarely
at those who stood before him his face
firm situation tense big us cargo
helicopter ch-47 chinook
shoot down yesterday at delta helicopter
crash crew survive and get inside
firebase another helicopter come for
pickup crew cannot too many vc no
aircraft can get close to delta too many
machine gun
finally he gave their orders you the
11th airborne battalion go on to
firebase charlie just north of delta
tomorrow bow you are strongest battalion
i know you only 56 strength you should
be 836 paratroopers officer and enlisted
you have only 471 still you my strongest
i put you in most critical place your
mission occupy positions on old
fireplace and defend it at all costs
[Music]
peter kama turned to john and peter comm
is the senior overall senior adviser at
the brigade level he is
he turns to john duffy and says that
string of hilltop firebases it's known
as rocket ridge it is the key to the
defense of kontoum and therefore all of
central vietnam
um after the briefing
comma and duffy talked outside john
asked why do they call it rocker rocket
rain rocket ridge peter explained the
americans named it rocket ridge years
ago the enemy used to used to fire 122
millimeter rockets from its heights down
onto the highway and villages below the
us army built a series of firebases to
control the ridgeline denying it to the
nva now the communists want it back they
need it for their invasions plan their
invasion plans he went on it's april
fool's day but this is no joke a rocket
ridge is vulnerable hell the whole
region is vulnerable we're facing the
better part of two nva divisions plus
reinforcements friendly forces are
grossly outnumbered 17 kilometers north
to south vietnamese 22nd division is not
well regarded their new commander
colonel dat doesn't have a good
reputation he's not an effective leader
17 kilometers southwest who knows how
long the arvin rangers can hold out
against a major attack in between is
over 20 kilometers of rocket ridge and i
know the bad guys want it arvind
artillery along that ridgeline impedes
their maneuver against ton khan and will
disrupt any movement south along highway
14 toward kontoum
the firebases also block his direct path
eastward should he choose to advance
over those hills the direction of such
attack would likely go right over top of
charlie
understood duffy said comma continued
nva divisions pushed across the dmz la
two days ago looks like they're planning
something just as big here intel warns
that a thrust out of cambodia towards
saigon is possible
we're looking at an all-out invasion of
the south by vor by north vietnam
and we've got no american troops in the
highlands we've pulled most of our units
out of vietnam here in two core there
are no american ground forces left at
all
they're all gone
we've got only a few us army helicopter
companies and some u.s air force tack of
tack air available and the b-52s out of
guam or thailand thailand when we get
them that's it winning the fight on the
ground is now up to the arvin
peters brow lowered
this brigade was a strategic reserve for
the nation it's now been committed the
11th airborne battalion was our reserve
within the brigade now you're being
committed
that leaves nothing there's nobody else
no one to come in behind you no
reinforcements you're it
you've got to hold at charlie and stop
the nva from crossing rocket ridge they
cannot take that high ground and gain
access along highway 14 straight into
contour
it's quite a responsibility
yeah and when you've got a a map in here
that kind of lays it out um
it's
it's it's sort of like a classic sort of
military operation where you can see
exactly this beautiful high ground the
the the low ground that it gives access
to the way it sets up sort of being able
to cut across vietnam and split the
country into
control supplies and all this it's like
a classic military
critical this is a decisive engagement
or decisive ground
peter comma studied john and noted
you're the lone advisor with this
battalion that's usually a team of three
two officers and an nco you'll need a
backup in case you get wounded only an
american can call in u.s airstrikes and
helicopters that includes medevac i've
got a special forces lieutenant i'll
give you he's away on mid-tour leave
right now but he'll be back in a few
days he can join you then john thought a
moment no thanks i've got it i don't
plan on getting wounded and i've been
working alone with these guys for a
while now not a problem
okay but if you change your mind let me
know
kama's assessment of duffy he thought he
was nuts but he took him to be confident
and brave very much up to the task at
hand peter would do all he could to get
him the support he knew he'd need to
defend charlie
as an afterthought comma added
tomorrow's easter sunday god be with you
duffy smiled
thanks happy easter
did you talk to peter kama i did uh at
length and peter regrettably passed away
this past year
so it's a shame and and peter is the one
that submitted duffy for the medal of
honor because of this action
that medal of honor got downgraded to a
distinguished service cross at the time
with new evidence and some of that was
the voice recording that i talked about
peter resubmitted the award in 2012
and pushed he got centered in no way
involved other
senators congressmen
but that whole bureaucracy took years to
finally get accomplished and it's just
it's too bad that peter didn't live to
see all this come to fruition
or live long enough to see the book and
it's in its final form
i had to read this section here because
we do have a lot of military folks that
listen to this and this is a pretty cool
gear list each paratrooper carried this
is getting ready for this operation to
secure this hill each paratrooper
carried an m16 rifle seven magazines of
ammunition hand grenades a small
entrenching tool a canteen and combat
rations both vietnamese and american sea
rations the officers also carried 45
caliber pistols each company took two
m60 machine guns nine m70 grenade
launchers and a number of law or
anti-light anti-tank weapons claymore
mines and 60 millimeter mortars the
headquarters company weapons platoon
brought the heavier 81 millimeter
mortars and 90 millimeter recoilless
rifles
piles of ammo water cans
medical supplies along with food
provisions sat ready to be hauled to
charlie on later lifts after the
paratroopers were in place
duffy brought what many thought was
overkill but he knew it was not he had a
carbine and the standard army backpack
radio known affectionately as the prick
25.
the prc25 fm radio his assigned radio
telephone operator rto carried that in
duffy's rucksack he had a long folding
whip antenna for the radio three extra
batteries and a commercial long range am
fm radio to monitor armed forces vietnam
network news broadcast
he filled the remainder of the space in
the pack with rations a few cans of sea
rash and fruit extra socks a poncho
liner four fragmentary grenades and four
smoke grenades
he stuffed his uniform pockets as well
he filled the four large shirt pockets
and cargo pant pockets with two signal
panels compass signal mirror strobe
light small flashlight knife p-38 can
opener map notebooks wrapped in plastic
pens for writing plus markers for his
map on his web belt and harness he'd
fastened 28 20 round ammo magazines four
smoke grenades two fragmentary grenades
flares snap links a sharp killing knife
two water canteens and a medical kit
that included compressed bandages
band-aids tourniquets morphine and a
self-injection blood volume expander he
also clipped on two emergency aircrew
survival radios
pretty good loadout it it is and very
few other advisors ever carried those
air crew survival radios john was very
insightful because in the end uh one of
those survival radios is what's going to
save his life and the life of those who
survived that battle yeah having a
backup radio and then having another
backup radio to that back already the
radio that come out came after the 110
was the 112. so when i got in in the
seal teams we would get issued the 112
which is the same concept right but i
had to use that 112 a couple times just
in admin situations but you know your
main primary radio floods out right and
one thing that was nice about those
prc112s they were relatively waterproof
compared to every other radio we had so
sometimes they would come in handy and
apparently duffy knew that yeah yeah
well it certainly it certainly did yeah
in his backpack radio it was a prick 25
i think earlier i might have said prick
77 which was a later rating yeah yeah
put 25 for him
um
again you've got a map in in the book
here
as these guys they get inserted into
this ridge line it's a ridge line that's
what it is
um
and this one battalion gets assigned
this one
section of the ridge line this section
of the ridge line is called charlie
we will refer to some of the stuff and
again get the book so you can you can
see this stuff visually but charlie one
is a section of this ridgeline that's
sort of a saddle
and then there's charlie 2 which is a
null to the south
and charlie 3 is a little null to the
north right
and there's
four companies that make up the
battalion and each one of these
companies at this juncture has about a
hundred guys maybe just over a hundred
guys each
um the companies are
one eleven one twelve one thirteen one
fourteen right
and headquarters company in addition to
that and the headquarters company is
110. right
um
there and so they spread out kind of on
this ridge line
with 113 on the on the north knoll
111's in the saddle 112s on the south
knoll and then 114 has the far
kind of south flank
and and i guess the 110 is sort of
on top of charlie too
right yeah charlie two's got the
headquarters 110 and then it's got those
two other companies uh one uh defending
principally the south west and the other
the or the southeast and the other no
southwest and the other the north
northeast
and again just to simplify this if
you're only listening
it's a ridgeline right and there's
several knolls and some saddles on the
ridgeline and these guys get inserted to
lock down this whole thing and i think
it's important to mention that ridgeline
is rising to the north
and and some of it there's there's high
terrain overlooking the the knolls that
you just discussed
from the northwest
so bow is going to become concerned that
he doesn't like this terrain
because yes he's on a ridge but the
ridge is getting higher to the north
there is
overlooking higher terrain to the
northwest
that he's below and then and you may get
to it there's a very threatening finger
of knolls pointing at his position from
the south
yeah it is a tenuous position yes to say
the least um
these guys get in position it
relatively smooth but you you say here
follow on helicopter lifts brought
shovels sandbags additional ammunition
water food as well as medical supplies
headquarters equipment a few personal
items
i had to i had to bring this up
duffy quickly retrieved his folding
aluminum lawn chair from the landing
zone it was a small extravagance in
which he took pride in having along
paratroopers duly harassed him
as he carried it up back up the hill
and then there was the air mattress
where he stuffed into his rucksack it
might turn into a hell of a fight but
john duffy intended to make it as
comfortable of a fight as possible
that's true i can't imagine they'd be i
can't imagine actually that aluminum
chair i remember guys occasionally bring
like not not into combat but going to a
range or something right you know you'd
be out on a range all day sighting and
weapons or whatever and someone would
show up and these days you know the
aluminum chairs are pretty nice i
remember one guy had one that was like
an aluminum recliner and it had a
self-contained umbrella on it so we're
all out in the in getting beat down in
the sun this is a seal yeah yeah and
he's of course like got his feet up with
a with a freaking
hel uh uh
umbrella a sun umbrella over him uh and
he kind of won we're all jealous you
know of course we're gonna make fun of
him and
you know tell him he's a wimp but we
were kind of jealous at the same time so
duffy duffy's got his aluminum chair
john was comfortable only for a short
time which i'm sure we'll get to yeah
uh
fast forward a little bit and again
you put an incredible amount of research
and detail of this so
get the book to understand the full
picture i'm going to fast forward a
little bit to
here we go the radios came alive at dawn
the tents chatter woke may he grabbed
his gear and headed to the command post
bunker he found bow already there
intently listening to radios with hai
duffy soon bent his tall frame through
the sandbagged entrance and joined them
fireballs firebase delta only two miles
to the south of charlie was under attack
it was monday april 3rd the day after
easter
bao turned to may
form and assault force of 112 and 114
companies leave the headquarters 110
company here to defend charlie 2. lead
task force may along that finger lake
ridge to the southeast if the enemy is
there push him off and kill him
the ridge has three knolls like knuckles
of a finger advance all the way to the
third knuckle and secure it we need to
control that high ground it should also
take some pressure off second battalion
may acknowledged with his usual positive
tone yes sir he had a request can i take
major duffy with me
no
we've only got one advisor i have to
have him with me you can call in vna af
airstrikes and artillery is immediately
available duffy can coordinate u.s air
power from here
so it's on
and meg it's again these are like
classic infantry assault maneuvers that
are happening
fast forward a little bit may ordered a
coordinated attack by his two companies
they moved up the hill shooting and
maneuvering to gain an advantage against
their foe they got close enough to see
hastily constructed enemy fortifications
with overhead cover
may called in
a strike of vnaf a1 skyraiders the
airplanes carried an awesome load of
ordnance including rockets bombs napalm
and machine guns before the dust settled
may ordered 11414
company to renew the attack
cho led with a reinforced platoon they
overran the bunkers with the loss of one
paratrooper killed and another wounded
four north vietnamese soldiers lay dead
the the mangled remains of a 51 caliber
machine gun sat nearby
may consolidated his task force around
the site and prepared to continue the
attack to the top of the hill the nva
didn't give him time they shot 75
millimeter recoilless rifle rounds they
swept down from the heights firing and
screaming more paratroopers fell but
they held their ground may organized a
counter attack of his own and soon
pushed the enemy back up the hill only
to run out of steam as the force
encountered stiff resistance the morning
turned to afternoon as the battle waxed
and waned
so this this had to be at least a little
bit different that these
the the nva is
they're ready to fight they're ready to
just engage
when for most of the war it was when
they get contacted they'll do some
damage and run away yeah as i said the
war had changed his complexion this was
a conventional nva assault and they're
going to find out they're up against
multiple nva battalions
the elements of the
64th nva regiment is what they're facing
and then they can end up before it's
over and done
facing a battalion from another regiment
so they're outnumbered somewhere in the
neighborhood of eight or ten to one on
that hilltown
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit just
before sunset the enemy threw a fresh
infantry company into the fight they
slammed down the western flank of the
paratroopers causing them not causing
them to bend but not break task force
may held
but would advance no further that day
the progress they'd made had cost a
dozen casualties killed and wounded
colonel bow faced the decision leave the
task force in place with hopes of at
least securing the first knoll the next
day or bring them back to charlie 2.
the short-handed battalion spread its
limited manpower thinly across firebase
charlie bow had three separate locations
to defend along the ridge stretching
over half a mile to end to end
he had further deployed a huge chunk of
his force almost a mile to the southeast
attempting to gain yet more real estate
in an increasingly costly fight
the sun set and all he had left to
defend charlie 2 was 1 10 company
consisting of the headquarters personnel
and weapons platoon bow issued his order
after dark task force may disengage
recover your dead and wounded and return
to charlie 2.
with as much stealth as possible may
brought his force off the knoll and
across the wide saddle
he led his exhausted men back onto
charlie 2 a little after 9 pm
112 and 114 companies returned to their
previous positions on the perimeter
that night may scratched out a letter to
his wife sen by the light of a small
flickering candle
he hoped he'd get it out on one of the
resupply helicopters
it read
this may be my last letter for a while
the situation is approaching critical
the colonel is doing all that is
possible the nva will surely push
forward
and we will do battle
i may soon fight in a ferocious fight
the commanders and paratroopers are
ready
perhaps all will not return from this
fight
that is the fate of soldiers serving
their
country my thoughts will always be with
you
my heart will always belong to you
my strength is a tribute to your love
our children are a testament to our love
do not worry when you hear reports of
the battle
i am ready and i know how to survive in
combat
i will come back home to you my precious
love
i will fight the dragons
and return to your arms
and i included his letter in there and
that took some discussion with him and
his wife to to see if we wanted to put
that in there but in the end we decided
to
and it just really
i i wanted this story to be as much a
human interest story as just a combat
account and that really shows the
the humanity of may and his family
yeah i know that's did did they have
like a copy of the letter uh it was a
recollection i think i don't know if
they have the actual copy but i was able
to get to get the words
yeah and again i mean i fast forwarded
you you go through the courtship and the
children like all that stuff and it's
it is very obviously a very human story
and here's this guy what's interesting
about that as i was reading that
you know i've read plenty of
sort of uh
i guess they call them death letters you
know in case i don't make it type
letters
and and here's mei who's writing uh hey
look it's coming but i'm gonna be okay i
know how to survive and i'm ready
that's a
a very positive attitude for him to have
going into this situation for sure and
she gets that letter uh
and she gets it right or right after she
got it then the news the available
public information of what's going on
in the highlands gets very dire and
disturbing
all right i'm going to fast forward a
little bit to where
the team has now been on the ground for
three days
it's been three days since the arrival
so here we go thursday april 6th arrived
with charlie once again shrouded in fog
eeriness settled over the hilltop
all wondered what the enemy was up to
behind the mist they could only imagine
on nom which is which means big brother
which is what they called lieutenant
colonel bao one of the nicknames they
gave him right
assembled his officers and staff
save big hung because of 113's distance
from the rest of the battalion he
summarized their situation and issued an
order that he'd relay to hang by radio
the nva have us surrounded
they hold the mountaintops they've
positioned their guns to shoot down the
helicopters
it is here we must do battle
it is here we must bleed them
do not let them take our positions
this battle is to the end
tell the paratroopers to fight bravely
tell them to aim all their bullets well
for we may lose the ability to resupply
dig in deep and prepare for combat
any trooper not ready to fight i want
him off the mountain
i'll not have him die with us
i'll not have him share in our glory
so that's a dire situation
uh
these
these anti-aircraft guns these 51
caliber
it seems like this is an extreme amount
of
enemy anti-aircraft weaponry that they
have
in this situation is that it was more
than we had seen inside of south vietnam
at any point up to that battle yeah they
had numerous 51 calibers that's a deadly
weapon against against helicopters yeah
that that's the impression i got as i as
i read that the way this battle unfolds
and it seemed like
most of the time
there was enough
i don't know if it's called air
superiority but there was enough
confidence in the helicopters look sure
there were some landing zones that would
be so bad
but it wouldn't last for very long or
they could put down fire and eventually
get in there right
this one is the the the nva is
definitely looking to deny access
from
the air yep they were they were
fast forward a little bit the fog lifted
shortly before noon duffy went back to
the to work running air strikes he
teamed with may and hai to integrate all
available fire support onto the most
most lucrative targets with the priority
of air support going against nva for off
offensives
far to the north and south little could
be allocated to charlie so there's other
battles that are taking place that are
soaking up a lot of the air support yes
and the biggest one was that thrust
across the militarized zone in the north
that was the and and when the south
started losing quang chi province the
enemy was just moving rapidly to the
south
and then once they came out of cambodia
uh towards saigon they got as far as an
lock before they were stopped but yeah
there was a worry on all fronts uh the
loss of quang chi province to the north
and possibly way city which was the old
imperial capital and then that threat
against saigon to the uh to the south uh
so the central highlands though it was
critically important for not getting
vietnam cut in half at the waste uh as
as the vietnam had done against the
french i mean we hear about diane bien
foo being the decisive battle
but really the the thrust across the
south and the destruction of french
group mobile 100
contributed to the end of that wars
against the french as much as any
so yeah all those worries but yeah
there's demands for air everywhere and
though the u.s is there to provide air
support and in the north some naval
gunfire uh it's it's stretched then
you say this john developed a technique
of constantly badgering forward air
controllers to divert their airstrikes
that were not avail that were not able
to hit their primary targets because of
weather or situational changes he got a
number of much-needed missions that way
so he would just stay on the radio hey
what do you got you got any extra ammo
is there anybody that can't drop is
anybody that needs to get rid of some
ammo and again that's john duffy if you
know john you can see him doing that
he's just like a brooklyn guy out there
trying to make it happen yep he won't
you won't let go
uh for the rest of the day duffy worked
with ford air controllers covey 507 531
and 546 putting in air force f-4
phantoms and navy a7 corsairs on the
finger
may and high added vienna af a1
skyraiders and a37 dragonflies to the
mix along with a number of artillery
barrages the effort produced good
effects with the destruction of bunkers
and mortars and two dozen secondary
explosions
they'd inflicted pain on their enemy
fast forward a little bit the day's good
weather ended clouds billowed around
charlie and the airstrike ceased for the
day the paratroopers faced the evening
with an ominous feeling that conditions
were developing for a big fight on
charlie
disturbing radio calls at 8 o'clock that
night confirmed those suspicions john
received the message in english over his
advisor channel at the same time the
second brigade transmitted it on the
arvin network in vietnamese
intelligence indicates the nva plan to
overrun charlie repeat
intelligence believes the nva intend to
overrun your positions
bow grabbed the handset from hai's radio
operator this is gray tiger request to
maneuver on offensive operations to take
the fight to the enemy i don't want to
sit in place on charlie and wait to
absorb the attack
the enemy has designed airborne doesn't
sit and wait it attacks
i'll consolidate leave one company on
charlie 2 and launch an attack with the
rest of the battalion
the reply came back immediately from the
brigade commander colonel lee colonel
lick himself
negative
defend in place
block any potential crossing of the
ridge
fight to the death on charlie those are
your orders
fight to the death
so bao being an airborne commander wants
to go on the attack he does yeah light
highly mobile forces just sitting there
defending uh waiting for the enemy to
amass his force and descend upon you
but they get the message loud and clear
that was their mission to stay there to
the bitter end and defend that that
hilltop
which they do in fine form and the only
reason there's going to be any survivors
at all is they are out of the ability to
to damage the enemy
so the few people left
are withdrawn off the hill
fast forward a little bit sunday marked
a week since the 11th airborne
battalions air assault onto charlie it
also marked a new conviction among the
paratroopers the line had been drawn in
the sand they would fight until victory
or until death
the weather cleared by noon helicopters
arrived with more ammunition water and
rations including some live chickens for
roasting they had also brought mail to
the delight of the beleaguered
paratroopers peter kama even put some
candy bars on the aircraft for john he
shared them with the others
april 11th fast forward april 11th 1972
this day hell unleashed its fury at a
place called charlie
at midnight john duffy's radio came to
life dusty cyanide this is kovy 555.
following message relayed from blue chip
through carbon outlaw arc light inbound
to target location per year request
estimated drop in 30 minutes
john rousted bow and high in the
operations bunker may join them there
high radioed the companies commanders
alerted their paratroopers
as the drop time approach
each crouched down in a foxhole trench
or bunker held his helmet on his head
and opened his mouth hoping to equalize
the pressure of the coming blasts that
he
had been told would be very close
terror rain from the sky
hundreds of 500 and 750 pound bombs fell
from the high flying b-52s the closest
hit only 300 yards from 1 14 company
blasting the nearest knoll of the finger
ridge exploding its shoulders and
smashing a swath of obliteration along
the ridgeline to the southeast
the earth shook
the destruction was horrific and lethal
debris rained down
even on nearby friendlies
the nva answered the blow with barrages
of artillery mortars and recoilless
rifle fire while they licked their
wounds and re-thought their attack plans
their shells blasted the hill but they
did little to paratroopers still lying
low in their trenches after the b-52
strike the shelling continued
sporadically through the night even so
those not standing watch were able to
fall back asleep for some moments of
rest fitful as it might have been
yeah those b-52 strikes john wanted them
badly of course priority was going a lot
of other areas
uh one thing that i do point out in the
book peter kama before he became the the
brigade advisor
was working with the commander of all
forces in vietnam uh
the deputy commander at the time general
wayan so he had a connection to the top
levels of of the
command in in vietnam and was able to
leverage that uh on
a couple of occasions to get some p-52
strikes diverted
but yeah john wanted those b-52s badly
and and he got that that first one
that night just after midnight
what's the closest you ever were when
one of those arc light strikes oh it was
a good ways away
it sounds like they were just
insane yeah before the john thinks that
he was the first one and i i've not been
able to confirm it john thinks he was
the first one to work b-52 strikes in
that close of proximity to friendly
forces
before that they were always tried to
keep him 500 meters away
he brought that down to 300 meters i
think in one case i don't remember was
this one or the next one but they said
hey you got to be at least 500 meters
away and john says yeah we are close but
knowing he wasn't nearly that far away
yeah it just turns i think you said
three
football fields
in length just total destruction just
destroys everything in that area it is a
normal arc light would be three b-52s
flying in in formation and and letting
all their bombs go that's quite quite a
massive
path of destruction
[Applause]
um
fast forward a little bit reports come
in of more nva soldiers only a few
hundred yards to the southwest
more kilos came in to resupply the
beleaguered 11th battalion both vn af
and american the 51 caliber machine guns
fired relentlessly the few choppers that
braved and approached took debilitating
hits before turning away
none were able to get through the deadly
wall of bullets nva machine guns blazed
away at any helicopter that came in
range
at least 10
51 caliber positions now ringed charlie
that's a nightmare
yep duffy turned to may those machine
guns are out there to kill they're doing
their job they're good yes big problem
for us problem for resupply and evacuate
wounded john nodded i'm worried the fire
is too intense they can't get in all
we're going to do is get more
helicopters shot down i'm closing the lz
tell me if you or colonel bau have a
problem with that duffy took the radio
handset from his rto seller 5-1 this is
dusty cyanide i'm closing to the i'm
closing the lz to huey resupply and
medevac helicopters they will not
survive the gunfire from the ridges of
ridgelines above
i repeat the lz is closed there is no
reason attempting the impossible
i've got to get rid of some of those 51
cals before we get any more kilos in
here
he put in more sets of f4s on the
surrounding machine gun positions and
asked covey to hit the suspected 130
millimeter gun positions with anything
else he had available john duffy had two
problems he must resolve if the 11th
airborne battalion was to survive kill
the anti-aircraft machine guns and
eliminate the 130 millimeter guns and i
haven't really mentioned 130 millimeter
guns yet they're they're in the book
but there was some heavy artillery
that the nva had
that was punishing the guys up on
charlie it was just pounded and pounded
and pounded that hilltop and john did
his best i mean that's a long-range
artillery weapon and he tried to get air
strikes in on him he will eventually get
another b-52 strike out there on him and
never throughout the battle was able to
completely eliminate those 130
millimeter guns yeah it sounds like he
suspected they were dug in like maybe on
tracks getting wheeled into the caves
and pushed back out to shoot exactly
they'd bring them out to fire and then
put them in the protection of the cave
fast forward a little bit april 12th
1972 exploding artillery shells took the
11th battalion shook the 11th battalion
paratroopers awake
the 1 11 company took the brunt heavy
artillery mortar rocket and recoilless
rifle rained down on hill 960.
charlie won
75 big 130 millimeter shells slammed
onto the hilltop
oh
[Applause]
so let me give you some perspective here
uh i was in a a in a
combat outpost in ramadi and we got hit
with
three
120 millimeter martyrs
and it was a shocking nightmare
and here they are taking 75.
130s
that is just i i can't even i can't
imagine what that what that's like on
top of one company and and i don't know
if we'll get to it but uh
it's either i think it's later uh
charlie uh took 300 rounds in just a
couple of hours one day
yeah i i remember seeing um
from that from that mortar strike i was
talking about there's 120 millimeter
we found pieces of frag the pieces of
frag are are they're you know when a lot
of times when people think of
fragmentation they think of these little
tiny things that are the size of a bb or
the size of you know like a
a little quarter inch piece of fragrance
no chunks there was chunks we found frag
that was
nine inches long and weighed like a
pound and a half just
gnarly
metal shards flying through the air
that's how you see that's why you see
guys sometimes they lose their entire
leg or they lose an arm if they get hit
with a piece that's just not some little
little tiny fragmentation it is a
massive chunk of steel flying through
the air so and that's i'm talking about
two or three
mortars hitting a combat outpost you're
talking about 75
even bigger shells
it's it's it's hard to it's hard to
comprehend what that does to you i mean
just the concussion alone from that
right and by the way i was sitting in a
concrete building by the way
you know i'm not sitting in a foxhole
with a with a poncho over my head right
that they that they dug and those
figures you know luckily john as i
mentioned earlier he kept a a log a
journal every day so i've got all the
call signs of the facts the type of
aircraft number of aircraft location of
aircraft that were brought in and the
counts that they made at the time of the
artillery strikes
charlie one received 70 rounds of
of 130 millimeter fire
what a nightmare
um
fast forward a little bit the artillery
stopped and what that only means one
thing the artillery stop the nva company
rose from the steep gully less than 100
yards to the west of charlie 1 trench
line scores of enemy soldiers raced
forward the fight was on
the 1 11 paratroopers reacted in
well-practiced battle drill lieutenant
thin
the company commander quickly assessed
the situation claymore mines had
bloodied the lead elements of the attack
his soldiers thinned the advancing enemy
ranks with disciplined well-aimed rifle
flyer they threw hand grenades in close
combat
so this is just
it's on
um
here's another one fast forward past
that skirmish a heavy artillery barrage
hit charlie 2 at 11 30. the 130
millimeter shells pummeled the hill
one slammed into bow's bunker
with a deafening explosion it turned the
place to rubble
broken timbers and shredded sandbags
covered the commander hai got there
first he'd only been several yards away
may joined in seconds
they began pulling debris off on nam
their big brother
they summoned doc liu who came running
with duffy close behind
with the help of the nearby paratroopers
they pulled bow clear doc lou went to
work
but immediately looked up and shook his
head
their beloved commander was dead
hai took the ho the lost hardest of all
may didn't have time to grieve he was
now the commander all responsibility
rested on his shoulders
john duffy looked at the lifeless body
sad that bow had not been able to utter
his final words in death
a feeling overcame john he sensed what
colonel bowell's last thoughts must have
been
he had no doubt
he shared his notion with the others i
know what colonel bao wanted to say
before he died i hear his voice in my
heart
tell my wife i loved her true tell my
children to remember me tell my
paratroopers to never surrender
to you
my officers
one final salute
that's john duffy the poet but he felt
that in his heart and he noted those
words down at the time and those are on
his website of poetry i think probably
in his book as well yeah
so now they've lost this
their leader their beloved their beloved
leader big brother colonel bao
killed in one of these
insane barrages of artillery
things don't get much better fast
forward a little bit covey brought in a
flight of a7 corsairs off a navy carrier
of the coral sea their first pass on the
south perimeter went terribly wrong they
dropped short of the target
their bombs hit the 1 14
company trenches killing three and
wounding seven
frustrated and angry john moved the
strike well to the southwest where he
could expend their remaining ordnance
before heading back to the ship he
targeted 75 millimeter recordless rifle
and anti-aircraft gun positions duffy
had also forward
duffy also had forward air controllers
continue to place strikes on the 130
millimeter gun positions in the hills
far to the southwest he firmly believed
those big guns were on rails that backed
them into tunnels after they had fired
he figured that's how they had survived
all the airstrikes that made them tough
targets but they had to be killed
at 4 pm 130 millimeter round hit the
entrance to duffy's bunker knocking him
unconscious
he regained his senses but felt warm wet
blood covering his head and chest
his back hurt too where more shrapnel
had torn into him
his ears rang he couldn't hear his head
throb from a horrendous concussion
rubble and body surrounded him
john shoved the closest guy and said
come on let's go
the guy lay still he didn't move he was
dead
john couldn't believe it all of them
dead save his rto
yet john had lived
how could that be
how in the same space and time could
five men die and he live
he stared at the carnage in shock
finally he grabbed his car 15 and
dragged himself from the rubble not at
all appreciating the seriousness of his
own injuries
his radio operator followed stunned
without the radio he was severely
wounded and badly dazed
he wandered off stumbling and babbling
incoherently john called after him he
started to run after him hobble after
him actually
he had only taken a few steps when an
artillery round exploded nearby
shredding the young man who'd served
john so faithfully
with no time to grieve major duffy
returned to his crumpled bunker to
retrieve his radios
so he
about gets killed in that one
um
yeah he ends up being he was wounded
five
different five separate times during the
battle
this is probably a good time to talk
about some of these books some of these
poems uh that that major duffy wrote
he ended up writing he's written six
books of poetry and one of the books as
i mentioned earlier is called the battle
for charlie
and and
it's
a chronological book of poems about what
he experienced and i got one of the
here's one of those poems that relates
exactly to what happened the poem is
called direct hit
and it says
the dust is choking
the others are dead
the radio still talks
i must be alive
the loud ringing noise will it ever stop
i am half buried in someone else's grave
my bunker is destroyed
i crawl over the bodies all are dead or
dying
i must kill that gun
that's probably his biggest frustration
out of that battle is he could not
silence those 130 millimeter guns
they kept they kept firing
yeah and when you're talking about again
these barrages that are 30 40 50 60 70
80 shells
that's incomprehensible to me it really
is it's just i i can't even fathom what
that must be like sitting in a foxhole
with 30 or 40 or 50 of these
explosions with the metal it's just it's
insane to even think about
[Music]
[Applause]
so
now we're going to april 13th i'm going
to fast forward a little bit
and by the way you i'm fast forwarding
past
just about every page is filled with
heroic insane combat
um fast forward a little bit though high
shook john duffy awake in the middle of
the night
vc surround one 113 they attack big hung
need help and there's two there's two
characters called hung skinny hung and
big hung right
um
they're they're both leaders in the
companies
john raised up on an elbow his head
still pounded from his concussion he
felt groggy and disoriented his thoughts
not yet totally clear
he ached in every inch of his being need
to focus high went on hung here many
hundred soldier move in the dark
then attack he think big attack maybe
hold battalion
duffy asked what time is it zero 100
christ one o'clock in the [__]
morning do you really think they're
coming at him with a major attack in the
middle of the night
we hurt them in daytime yesterday
maybe try different tonight maybe so
okay let me see what i can do can you
request artillery flares be ready to go
in case i'm able to get some tack air
john gone on his radio any covey any
covey this is dusty cyanide need some
help any covey any covey
he was surprised by an immediate reply
hello dusty cyanide this is cubby521
and eventually that night he gets a
uh a specter on station ac 130. god
bless him
gets them on and is able to
prevent that attack from being
overwhelming right
fast forward a little bit duffy moved
about the hilltop with what many saw as
reckless abandon the long radio antenna
swaying over his head marked him as a
target for major john duffy though he
was a man on a mission he had one
purpose in life and that was to direct
airstrikes trying to save this battalion
his battalion that was his task his duty
nothing else mattered
he'd jump in a trench work a target
watch the fighters roll in and release
their wardens then pick up and run to
another trench for a better view of his
next target enemy gunners caught on to
his strategy and opened up on him as he
ran shells bursting all around him
so this is one of the things that you
see throughout this battle is he just
he's doing whatever he needs to do to
get in a position where you can actually
see and call and direct this fire in a
most effective way exactly
and and every time he does it he's
putting his life at risk and seeing a
big ass antenna on a guy there's no more
primary target especially in this group
than an american with a radio on his
back he's over what was he six foot six
for three yeah
yeah this guy had to be
the most targeted human
imaginable at this point they only see
one american he's obviously the ones
calling in air strikes and he's running
around like a maniac
well that's where i came up with the
title for this book because we look at
duffy i mean he's the biggest hero of
the battle but also may and high and
these other guys and then there's a
lieutenant lap that's going to turn up
in this too and doc lew and all of them
it just is as i got into researching and
writing the most extraordinary valor
that i had
seen in anything that i've
that i've looked at that just really
one hell of a a fight
yeah no it's
like i said every page i mean i i guess
maybe this battle starts
maybe page 110 or 115 or 120 in the book
but like every page after that
there's there's
a heroic scene
speaking of which captain skinny hong
had a hard fight in the saddle he'd
pushed two platoons onto the lz through
stiff resistance a larger enemy force
came out of the gully to meet him the
112 companies struggled to hold but
slowly gave ground a little after 2 pm
the nva moved around their flank forcing
hung to withdraw back inside charlie 2.
the lz could not be retaken may grabbed
the radio handset and put in two flights
of skyraiders on the saddle
major lay van may had one last idea for
salvation he summoned lieutenant thin
brother thin i need you to take your
company 111 to the east those who can
still fight i know your numbers are
small but we have to do this find a good
spot secure it establish a new lz we are
running out of ammunition we need water
we need food we need medical supplies
we've got to get our wounded out
finn displayed his normal paratrooper
zeal yes sir we will get it done
they're trying to establish another lz
because these lz's that they've been
trying to secure are just getting
overwhelmed the the nva know that if
they establish an lz then they'll be
able to get resupplied
um there's a you know a small battle
that i hate to even say a small battle
but they try and secure it get pushed
back and finally may decides hey
let's find an alternate landing zone
somewhere yeah maybe a little quieter
out to the east out there so move movies
to get one and and i would mention that
lieutenant ting
is uh is one of may's favorite
lieutenant's favorite favorite
commanders they're they're close yeah
and you go into their relationship in
the book
so they go out
and i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
at dusk i saw the band of paratroopers
returning from the east
he rushed to the far side of the trench
line waiting as the small group moved
closer he saw
1 14 company soldiers mixed with the
small band of 111 company survivors
all appeared wary but in good order
carrying the wounded and dead
may joined high
they looked for lieutenant khan they
didn't see him
they didn't see any officers or
sergeants
from 111 company
may scanned the bodies
looking down at one he shuddered it was
lieutenant tin
his beloved lieutenant tin
with emotion filling his voice one of
the paratroopers reported to may lots of
nva
we fought through and got to a good lz
site then they hit us in force machine
guns mortars and recoilless rifles
more than a hundred enemy
we fought hard but couldn't hold them
the nva shot lieutenant tin in the head
he's dead
they killed mr ba and lieutenant khan
and sergeant long others are dead too
many wounded
the 111 company was gone destroyed in
battle
between yesterday's fight on hill 960
and the excursion to secure a new
landing zone the enemy had killed all
the officers and sergeants and whittled
the unit down to a handful of effective
fighters
may placed those few still walking into
the perimeter sector manned by
headquarters company
soldiers stacked the dead on the growing
rows of corpses and carried the severely
wounded to the medical aid station where
doc liu conte tended them as best he
could
most medical supplies had run out the
badly wounded lay there helpless and
frustrated dealing with the agony of
their pain and the guilt of not being
further worth in the battle
high in may found duffy still working
airstrikes may told him there will be no
new lz nva hit 111 company hard many
casualty
tin is dead
all officers and sergeants dead
the news shocked duffy but he remained
resolute okay
then we fight with what we've got
i'm going to rain airstrikes down on the
bastards hi
you will you do the same with vnaf and
artie yes duffy
good let's get to it we've got some
fighting to do
desperate to desperate situation yeah
but they do you know
duffy well and and may too may had a
moment of
uh i won't say despair that's too much
but but a moment where he was just
doubting what was going on
duffy helped rally him and he came right
back and
and stood as the rock of the battalion
and duffy is reigning airstrikes down
and that's all that they could do i mean
that's their situation they've got their
orders they've got the situation that
they're in and they'll make the very
best of it that they can
april 14 1972
fighting continued through the night
from time to time friendly artillery
flares drifted across the dark skies
swaying beneath tiny parachutes lighting
sections of the battlefield beneath them
shapes moved on the ground paratroopers
took care they only fired when they had
sure targets well within range each man
sighted carefully breathed out and
pulled the trigger with an oh so steady
squeeze
ammunition had become frighteningly
scarce
the north vietnamese fired with much
more abandoned they had ammo they were
being resupplied
the paratroopers were not
the attacks come through the night um
a heavy barrage of enemy shelling
shattered the morning calm
artillery mortars rockets and recoilless
rifles the reign of explosions didn't
stop the battle for charlie raged into
its 12th day
as he done so many times during the
battle john duffy got up out of the
trenches and braved exploding artillery
to get a view of the enemy gun positions
he moved to the edge of the perimeter
radio on his back with its recognizable
antenna high over his head enemy fire
hit close by he moved more fire he moved
again a north vietnamese recoilless
rifle shell exploded in the ground
beside him fragments ripped into his
left arm he put pressure on his wound to
slow the bleeding and then grabbed his
radio handset as a flight of u.s army
ah-1 cobra attack helicopters checked in
dusty cyanide this is cougar 3-8
cougar 3-8 glad to have you on station
i've got enemy troop movement along the
finger to the south southeast of charlie
give me some runs there a lot of 51 cal
fire in the area if you see any please
engage
the team of three cobra gunships made
several passes over the finger expending
all their ordinance
they headed a calm tomb to con tomb for
what for more fuel and ammunition duffy
watched them go what an awesome killing
machine he thought cobras carried
52 rockets on their stubby wings with 4
000 rounds of machine gun and 300 rounds
of grenades in their movable nose
turrets
a few mounted a deadly 20 millimeter
vulcan gatling gun with 950 high
explosive rounds
the cougar flight called as they
departed we'll be back dusty
another covey 5-3-4 came on station and
worked more strikes against the several
machine guns john identified trouble was
when the fast jets dropped their bombs
close to the gun positions they only
quieted them for a time once the jets
departed the guns were soon back in
operation only a direct direct hit
really did the job john concluded that
cobra helicopters were the best in
putting ordinance right into the gun
pits and silencing the weapons for good
cobras
coming in hot
yeah that's a heck of a duel any cobra
pilot will tell you going against a 51
caliber is not a lot of fun at all
they were deadly against helicopters and
even cobras
and
well as you say there's more in the book
to be read but i've got one account in
there if one of our cobras taking a 51
hit and and the damage that it did yeah
talk us through it
uh well they were up uh i think it was
the day before
if i remember where i have it in there
but it was one of our our cobras up
there and there was a 51 they were going
against a 51 and took a round through
the front seat the front seater dave
mesa was leaning over working his turret
and the round came in just over his
shoulder
and would have hit him in the head or
the chest if he'd been sitting up
straight and not working his turret and
it went through the armor plate behind
his seat
and and wounded the pilot in the back
seat so they got the thing back over
by the highway by the base where the
second brigade was and landed the pilot
was pulled out in medevac and dave got
to spend the night with the with the
vietnamese airborne brigade headquarters
before he could get back to placou the
the next day
and there's a picture in the book of
dave standing there with the armor plate
that they'd removed out of the seat you
can see the hole that the 51 caliber
made in the aircraft it's uh yeah it's a
bad weapon for for helicopters yeah the
the armor's not doing a ton of good
against the 51 no small arms small arms
it helps of course the cobras in those
days the the canopy was just plexiglas
so you got no protection from that but
it did have armored seat and armor plate
behind the seat that would give you some
protection from small arms of course the
apaches today are they're
well suited to take all kinds of hits i
flew apaches the last six years of my
army career but yeah the cobra
could be damaged by 51 kills
uh
fast forward a little bit the second
airborne brigade hatched a plan for an
emergency resupply a huey approached
charlie from altitude it flew high to
minimize the risk from anti-aircraft
machine guns the paratrooper
paratroopers fixed their hopeful eyes on
the drama above once over charlie
streams of tracers stretched toward the
chopper the crew kicked out well packed
bundles of food ammunition and medical
supplies
they missed the mark landing outside the
perimeter the enemy got to them in a
flash
and they they were desperate by this
point they bought out of ammo no water
for days
out of medical supplies
very frustrating
fast forward a little bit more early
afternoon another flight of cobras
checked in chief warrant officer dan
jones flew lead i piloted the second
cobra flying on his wing
firebase charlie this is panther one
three
panther lead this is dusty cyanide i
have multiple targets for you all 51
caliber machine guns so what are you
thinking when you hear that
we've got our work cut out for us yeah
there's some trepidation oh [__] but
then again you get right back focus we
got to do what we can to help these guys
john duffy you know while as i said
we've talked a number of times since and
and i have always as i do to all the
special forces guys that are down there
that we're supporting i said whoa you
guys are just hanging it all out down
there on the ground i'm sure glad i'm in
a helicopter uh don john has said every
single time i'm glad i wasn't in that
helicopter and i'm glad i was on the
ground you guys have no you're up there
with this little tinfoil around you
taking all these rounds getting shot
right at you there's no way i would want
to do that
okay john i understand that i still have
tremendous respect for you on the ground
and i would not would not want to be
there
the crews knew the risk 51 caliber
machine guns seemed designed
specifically to shoot down helicopters
they'd done plenty of damage over the
past weeks
panther one three calmly acknowledge
roger dusty cyanide we're inbound give
us the positions when we get there the
cobras made several attacks on enemy
guns bullets streamed past their
cockpits as the nva gunners tried to
bring them down attack helicopter pilots
knew that rolling in on a 51 position
was always dicey tracers came at them
and missed by a few feet pilots tried to
get rockets onto the machine guns before
the enemy got lucky and blasted them out
of the sky
the pilots held steady focusing on
controlling their helicopters lining up
the gun sights and shooting
panther 1-3 fire team took small arms
hits but kept running at their targets
again and again and again
john duffy observed throughout the
shootout taking it all in commenting to
himself
they're coming in out of the sun going
in going for the high gun first that's
good [__] green and red tracers crossing
in front of them they're taking fire
from everywhere
there they punched off a salvo of
rockets right on target the gunners were
surely blown up in that explosion
wingman rolling in on the second gun
they're keeping at it it's a dance of
death i love those guys badass cobra
pilots so steady under such heavy fire
god i'm glad i'm on the ground
[Music]
the panther lead radioed dusty cyanide
panther one three be advised running low
on fuel out of ammo we're breaking
station for rearm refuel
roger one three four gun crews destroyed
four guns taken out good work
hurry back
how long are you on station for in that
scenario is that like five minutes oh
it's more than it's probably
15 minutes or so
number of runs
how can you tell when you're getting
shot at us because you're seeing tracers
yeah you see trey sometimes you see
tracers sometimes you don't uh that
first tour when i got shot down the
mohawk by a 37 millimeter anti-aircraft
i didn't see anything until my whole
right wing exploded so i didn't even see
any tracers but yeah we'd the 51s should
routinely see tracers now we in the seal
teams we would say tracers work both
ways so you can tell where you're
shooting but people can also tell where
you're shooting from
is it when you see tracers can you start
to track them back to where the gun is
yeah in fact that's how we'd see so
that's the gun position that's where the
tracers are coming from yeah
is it better to be leedberg or wingman
i don't know that much
matters i mean on the first run it's
probably better to be lead because they
may not see or know you're coming until
you roll in and start shooting and then
they're ready for number two
but once you make more than one run and
we've made several runs that day on
different positions and they know well
that you that you're there and they're
trying to get you
is it your speed that that makes you
safe like how what are you doing to just
to increase your survivability
shooting um
yeah i don't think it's speed and a
helicopter it's just
luck i mean they they can't get right at
you that first time
most of the time they can't now when i
was shot down and captured those were 51
calibers too and maybe a couple things
larger and there were several weapons
positions engaged me at the same time
and i saw tracers all around the cockpit
and then we started taking hits so it's
just i think it's difficult for them to
get that first round right on you and so
hopefully you can get some rockets on
him before he gets his aim close enough
where he can bring out of the sky
it's not a desired target a cobra
against a 51 is not desired it has to be
we wouldn't just go out looking for 51
positions to engage in fact if we were
just out on a mission we saw some 51s
probably turn it over to a faq or
whatever and we'd just
clear
but in this case you know there were
lives on the line and we had to do what
we could do to help
luckily we got through it okay not
taking any 51 hits as i pointed out
that other panther flight did take 51
hits
what does it look like
because i i had the experience where i
was up in
fallon nevada we were doing training
with the helicopter squadrons
and
it was i was in my first seal platoon so
i wasn't
didn't know what i was doing and i was
calling in a helicopter to pick us up my
squad we were out on a training mission
and i was calling them in to pick us up
and it's the desert
and i'm standing there kind of standing
up and i'm calling this aircraft and
this helicopter's i think there's i
think it's so obvious
where we are and i said hey you know i'm
right here you know go ahead and put it
down you know to our west and he's like
i don't see you and i mean
if you if i would had to bet money i
would have bet
a month's paycheck that this guy easily
saw he couldn't see us at all because
what i didn't realize at the time as a
young seal is he's looking at
you know many many many square miles of
stuff and i'm just looking up the sky at
one or two helicopters so it's real
obvious
when you're overhead
in the in in this situation can you see
the friendly forces can you can you get
an idea where john duffy is are you
close enough to the ground to see the
guy's expressions like what's it like
from that perspective yeah you can see
guys on the ground um can you tell who's
who can you tell no
friendly from not usually i mean if you
get low enough and close enough and can
pay enough attention then you can
because the nva you're mostly wearing
either green or tan uniforms it looks
different than a lot of pith helmets on
uh
and some regular but yeah you can
but as you said it's difficult to focus
your view exactly where you need to
focus your view uh and so when john was
working with us as guns he's not so much
at least in that situation going against
the guns he's not so much describing
where he is exactly he's describing
where the weapons positions are so he's
keying that off of various pieces of
train hey you see that ridge you see
that knuckle
that that direction
and there and then you know eventually
we get the tracers coming up so we can
see it now later when we come back he is
trying to describe his position to us of
course it was dark then we couldn't see
him but we could see fires and adjust
routinely to take that back a little bit
when we were extracting special forces
teams uh out of the out of the jungle
they would describe to us where they
were and all and we could generally see
them on the ground unless they were
hidden by the jungle canopy so we could
we could pick them out
uh so yeah the long answer the question
i can fully understand your situation of
fallon where you say hey guys we're down
here we see you and we're up you know i
don't know what altitude they were but
anywhere from several hundred feet up to
maybe a thousand or two thousand feet
they're looking out and especially
fallon over an expanse of desert as far
as they can see
uh and okay where are you so they yeah
you need some focus and i had the uh
aircraft panel sewed inside my floppy
hat and i thought oh i'm such a pro i'll
just break out my fl you know this
little orange whatever six inch square
can you see me now the guy's like you're
an idiot
now what does work and is helpful is uh
is uh flashes
we can see the mirror you can see
exactly okay that's where that guy is i
see his mirror
uh and we do that with the teams we pick
up use mirrors
or if the jungle is too thick for mirror
they'd get us close by describing where
their position was and then they just
pop smoke
and then you say okay i see orange smoke
or whatever yeah that's us and you have
their position exactly yeah and duffy
ends up using a mirror in this
all right going back to the book fast
forward a little bit airstrikes
continued other teams of cobras worked
vn af a1 skyraiders and us jet fighters
dropped more
napalm and high explosive bombs on the
advancing enemy as well even so the nva
attack intensified pressuring the south
vietnamese defenders the enemy overran
security outpost they pushed into the
perimeter of charlie to itself
human waves of nva came forward shouting
surrender you'll live fight back you'll
die but the paratroopers fought
vigorously picking up the closest
targets aiming and shooting
hold the trenches don't fall back
fire shoot those guys over there
chaos ruled the front it became an
inferno of smoke dust flame and noise
the world convulsed in a crescendo of
crackling cracking gunfire and deafening
explosions of artillery the wine of
attacking aircraft the thunderous boom
of their bombs and the sucking roar of
the napalm they dropped paratroopers
fought with all they had they fought
with grit and determination they fought
for their buddies in the pride of the
11th airborne they fought inspired by
those vietnamese paratroopers who had
gone before those who had sacrificed so
much in historic battles of old they
fought until their bullets were gone
after that they turned to grenades and
knives
many died swinging their empty rifles as
clubs
the brave paratroopers withstood the
onslaught with fierce determination
still
their enemy pushed taking patches of
earth inch by inch paying dearly for
every small gain
finally the nva overran charlie
southwest perimeter they occupied much
of one 114 company's defensive position
and paused to catch their breath among
the mingled dead of both sides
duffy got on the radio to major peter
comma at 2nd brigade
seller five one seller five one this is
dusty cyanide prairie fire prairie fire
prairie fire i am declaring a prairie
fire emergency we are being overrun
john defaulted to a phrase familiar to
him from his earlier special forces work
behind enemy lines in laos prairie fire
meant a special operations team was
about to be overrun and all available
assets were brought to bear
peter comma knew what john needed and
translated the statement into his into
words more commonly understood by
conventional military forces he declared
a tactical emergency or tac e across all
of two core
this required every available asset to
be redirected to support the
paratroopers on firebase charlie john
duffy would now get everything flying in
the skies over central south vietnam
john may and high got busier than they
ever had been working flight after
flight of supporting aircraft
[Music]
prairie fire emergency
yep
and this is the end is coming and uh it
is pretty amazing with all the firepower
that they had at their disposal how how
determined the nva were to carry this
attack to its uh to fruition
as they just kept pouring
battalion after battalion in there
until they carried the day but they
suffered horrendous casualties which we
talk about the impact of that as we get
at the at the end of the book
fast forward a little bit
the enemy delayed only a short while
before getting back up and continuing
their assault
they were about to overrun the 11th
battalion
dusty cyanide this is cougar 3-8 inbound
welcome back 3-8 enemy advancing rapidly
from the west and southwest battalion
strength heaviest from the southwest
expand on that formation
roger dusty will give him hell
and again it's incredible you can hear
some of these calls
i listened to these calls
cougar 38 and and
and duffy
just sounds
calm cool and collected
it's hard to hear him sometimes but when
you do hear him
it's like they're talking about you know
past me the ketchup yeah but because he
knows to survive he has to be you can't
you can't get in the panic and start
screaming and hollering on the radio and
nobody's going to understand what you're
saying or what you need so
to survive he has to stay calm and
measured
cougar 38's heavy fire team of three
cobras came in from the northeast they
drew intense enemy aircraft fire enemy
anti-aircraft fire dropping to just
above the trees to minimize their
exposure they flew past duffy in may
then continued right into the face of
the attack
duffy commented what guts those guys
have never seen anything like it right
on the deck those crazy bastards are
going to kill themselves to save us
goddamn heroes
each aircraft fired its entire
ammunition load on one pass pilots
launching pairs of rockets as fast as
their fingers could press the firing
button front seat gunners working their
turret weapon incessantly reigning death
and destruction
they annihilated the breadth of the
attacking formation the enemy staggered
he stumbled he fell he pulled back
needing to regroup once again the
courage of those three cobra crews
stalled the nva attack for now there was
no doubt the resolute enemy would come
again
may needed his other company he ordered
them to consolidate hours ago where were
they he called 113 company again
403 what's your progress
big hung responded we're trying lots of
enemy around us
may sternly order to break through and
get down here do it now we need the
battalion together
roger
may frowned in frustration hai used the
temporary lull to move about and assess
the situation he ran quickly among the
defenders
by then compressed into a much smaller
circle
they had something over a hundred
effective fighters left of the 471 man
battalion
hai moved from position to position
utilizing trenches as much as possible
but at times dashing into the open from
foxhole to foxhole he spent a few
minutes talking to each leader and spoke
with paratroopers along the way
bolstering their will to fight by
whatever means remained
high finished his circuit and rejoined
may in the command post trench
dusk settled in may called duffy who
joined them there
blood seeped from a gash in john's right
shoulder
he'd been hit yet another yet again by
another shell fragment
hai shook his head and began his report
we in bad shape
many dead more wounded i count only a
little over a hundred still can fight
most of them hurt
not much ammunition some have no ammo
even after take from dead
no way to stop next attack
next attack end 11th battalion
may look straight into hai's eye for
eyes for a time studying him digesting
what he just said he turned to duffy
ready to speak but paused
both minds churned through options
high spoke again casualty high ammo run
thin
cannot stop vc most of battalion dead
we stay longer all die
should leave
he leaned close to may and spoke in
vietnamese
gotta get this gotta get the battalion
off this [__] hill before the enemy
comes again
may nodded and responded in english yes
we order withdraw
duffy had a plan
he'd risk his life to try and save what
was left of the battalion
it seemed insane but it made perfect
sense to him
i will stay and try to delay the nva
maybe we'll get some more air in time to
make a difference
may insisted i stay with you we team
american and vietnamese we fight
together
nodded
full of determined grit
john duffy and lay van may would form a
two-man rear guard to allow what was
left of the battalion to break contact
and
escape two men
against two enemy battalions
may face his operations officer with a
look of resignation
you lead the battalion off charlie high
major duffy and i will delay as long as
we can
we're your rear guard
go about 800 meters northeast and wait
for one one three company i'll tell big
hung to move east until he finds you 113
is in good shape they have ammo and only
a few casualties you'll be okay
high saluted high saluted responding
smartly yes sir we go
he rallied the surviving paratroopers
those who could walk helped others who
couldn't
hai led the way off the hilltop toward
the sanctuary of the jungle below
excuse me it's a little emotional listen
you read all that um
yeah so that is the most heroic part of
the whole and there's heroism throughout
the book
but that is the most extraordinary act
of the of the whole
uh story is as john duffy and lay van
may uh deciding to be a rear guard
uh you know not knowing what their
chances of survival would be and it
looked pretty bleak but to do that uh to
allow the rest of the battalion to to
try to withdraw and get off the hill and
survive
so
yeah i don't know what they thought
their chances were of survival
i mean they're here they are getting
crushed
for 11 days at this point 12 days at
this point a couple of weeks the end the
nva has is fighting like they've never
seen him fight before they keep coming
wave after wave after wave the nva has
ammo the nva has resupply
it has that artillery pounding and yeah
the anti-aircraft
and and you know some some would say hey
guys you had the order to fight to the
death what the hell you doing with
drawing off the hill but they had no
further means to resist they were
just down to a few bullets left and guys
swinging their weapons uh to to fight
the enemy so i think i was exactly right
the next wave of attack from the nva
would have just
killed killed all of them and not
accomplished anything so the decision
was made to withdraw the survivors that
they had which at that point were just
over 100 people out of a 471-man
battalion to go ahead and try and get
those guys off off the hill
so there's two of them left
as dust turned to darkness a strange
silence brought a chill
it was as if may and duffy were in the
eye of a storm the enemy had fallen back
for the moment the artillery and mortars
fell still their battalion had gone
there was no chatter on the radio not a
sound on the hilltop save the whimpers
of the dying
they sat alone on the edge of what had
been firebased charlie waiting warily
for their enemies next move not doubting
for a moment he would attack
it was dark
suddenly the silence broke
whistling projectiles
hurled through the air incoming enemy
artillery erupted across the hilltop one
shell burst not far to their front the
explosion rocked them the blast
deafening the night for an instant it
lit their dirty blood-smeared faces
their hollow eyes set in hopeless
determination
a few more shells crashed around them
none as close as the first each blinding
flash shown upon the corpses
lying across the battlefield gruesome
evidence of the fight that had raged
over the past days
hundreds lay dead over the hilltop
outpost the bodies of south vietnamese
paratroopers mixed with those of their
determined north vietnamese enemy
the explosion stopped
the dark returned only the moans of the
wounded pierced the silence of the night
the stench of death filled the nostrils
of the last two men fighting
smoke choked their lungs they waited in
anticipation
they heard orders shouted from across
the field they sensed movement as
another attack wave swept toward them
the american adviser
leaned close to his vietnamese
counterpart and exclaimed [__] here they
come again
the reply in broken
but well-practiced english was resolute
i know we fight we fight more
the enemy once again rose from the
darkness tearing through the night
coming at them as vague shapes screaming
and shooting throwing grenades as they
advance closer and closer still both
john duffy and lei
von may knew this was the final assault
bullets whizzed by them
a grenade exploded ripping a hole in
mae's chest he gasped for air duffy
already wounded several times himself
looked over his left shoulder he nodded
satisfied seeing the decimated force all
that was left of the once mighty 11th
airborne battalion escaping down the
hillside
john and may were all that stood between
the remnants of the battalion and their
annihilation
they'd been out of food for days they
had no water left in their canteens
their ammunition was nearly gone but
still the americans and the american and
his south vietnamese comrade fought
and still the enemy came there was no
talk of surrender no thought but to kill
as many as they could before they were
themselves cut down where they squatted
on the edge of the ear of their
abandoned positions
levon may strain to speak fight duffy
fight
they battled with everything that
remained in their hearts and souls
but the end of their road was only
minutes away
they knew they were about to die
john duffy sensed his mortality as words
weld in his soul
death's moment is near i can feel its
flame soon it will be here it seems
strange no more
duffy's radio crackled dusty cyanide
this is panther one three back with you
duffy looked at may hot damn
he grabbed his radio handset roger
panther welcome back dusty where inbound
with rockets 40 mike mike and minigun
thought you might need a little more
help
[Music]
through the blackness the cobra crews
saw fires and chaos on charlie they
could only imagine the desperate
situation on the ground
duffy radioed the cobras enemy broken
broken through on the southwest charlie
overrun
there are three prominent fires on the
hilltop one big and too small the large
one is on the southwest part of the base
you see one small fire short distance
north and another 100 meters east of
that we are on the north edge of that
eastern small fire need you to shoot
right in front of us just to our west
but real close
roger dusty we got him
the cobras rolled in firing duffy
adjusted their
runs closer
the attacking enemy was about on top of
him he cut down several with his car 15
may did the same with his m16 but that
didn't slow them down a bit the enemy
was still charging just feet away
as the pink panthers began another gun
run
the head of the closest soldier exploded
hit by a 40 millimeter grenade from one
of the cobras his reflexes kept his legs
moving for a step or two before he
crumbled to the ground so close that
blood and tissue splattered on duffy in
may
right there panther keep it up the
cobras kept it up duffy delighted in hot
shell casings raining down from above
after a number of attack runs duffy
called panther panther lead this is
dusty cyanide you have broken the enemy
attack for now hundreds of bodies on the
field maybe a thousand but we cannot
hold
after a short break he continued we are
leaving firebase charlie now
stop them from following us whatever it
takes put your stuff all over the
hilltop now
the two ran for their lives may 1st
followed by duffy us army special forces
major john joseph duffy was the last to
leave firebase charlie
another cobra fight joined the team with
lieutenant forrest snyder in one of the
front teats that gave panther 1-3 a
heavy team of four aircraft forest was
the best gunner the panthers had the
team fired everything they had at the
hill
that had been firebased charlie they
turned toward home
the flight picked its way through the
mountains and valleys below a worsening
layer of scud clouds and a pitch black
of night what was left of the 11th
airborne battalion moved toward the
refuge of the valley below
that was
the end of the fight
on firebase charlie
yeah and i you know i i flew that i was
panther one three was dan jones and lee
and i was panther three six flying his
wing
we knew it was a bad situation at the
time and we did all we could to help but
we had no real full appreciation of
everything that was going on down there
until
i got all this information together to
write the book
uh john duffy well he credits his life
to several things including cougar 3-8
that came in there that day but he said
that that night uh he is and lay van may
the same thing they are alive today
because of what we were able to do
for them
which was just
doing what we could to help
so you're flying in this was this was in
pure darkness yeah we got there that
second run was night it was dark and and
clearly you guys don't have night vision
at the time so
it is you're looking at blackness
that was it was awfully dark the weather
was not good and getting worse and we
could see the fires on the hilltop
and yeah we're out there doing what we
can do in that situation and it was
duffy's description of those fires and
where he was in relation to those fires
and we just put our rounds down
and as dan jones recently commented to
me he said hey
we weren't exactly sure of
how close we were shooting to him we
couldn't see him we could see the fire
and he was just off the edge of one of
the fires
so it was just you know by the grace of
god we were able to get those rounds
right where they needed to be
and then move them a little bit as he
would give us adjustments and that as
close as we were firing to him
particularly with rockets rocket is not
with those 2.75 rockets are not a point
fire weapon it's not like the hellfire
and tow missiles that we've had since
uh so lucky that we could get them close
enough to be doing
the good that needed to get done
and and not inadvertently uh do damage
to those guys i mean we could have blown
duffy and may off the map if we'd have
been just a few feet off of where we
were putting our putting our rounds and
john duffy says this day one of the most
glorious feelings he's had in his life
is feeling hot brass rain down on top of
him
can you
can you see the targets at all are you
shooting just based on hey 50 meters in
front of the fire to the east that's
what we're doing no we couldn't see any
people
at all just the fires and
where our rounds were hitting and
exploding
and there's because there's no there's
no like overhead artillery putting a
loom up or anything it's just dark just
dark
how long were you on station for
after the other flight came in that i
don't you know it's hard to say uh i
don't know i guess it'd be the best
answer but i would imagine like 10 15
minutes and 20 minutes at the moment
yeah 20 at the most 10 to 15 probably
um because we got there we made multiple
runs the other fire team showed up and
joined with us and they they were fresh
on ordnance and everything so they had a
lot more to put down on the hilltop
[Music]
maybe 20 minutes probably closer to 15.
you know those uh cheesy
action movies where there's like the
hero is barely getting away as you know
but it doesn't actually happen in real
life except for it happens here yeah
uh after this
insane moment
of hot damn the cobras are here to bail
us out
uh
john and may stumbled and fell through
the darkness moving
quick swiftly in spite of their painful
injuries once the north vietnamese had
taken the hill the enemy advanced halted
for the moment the attacker's too
devastated to continue the cobras had
saved the day
amazingly duffy and may were still alive
they started out again duffy making an
urgent call on the move any covey any
covey this is dusty cyanide we are
withdrawing off charlie two nva
battalions in the open on a hilltop
request immediate diversion of a b-52
arclight strike to charlie
this is covey 531 standby dusty only a
few minutes later covey transmitted
dusty affirmative
carbon outlaw diverted arc light for
your target eta 20 minutes you need to
be 500 meters distance
be in defilade
open your mouths and keep your heads
down
duffy knew he was only a couple hundred
yards off the hilltop but he needed his
enemy bloodied so they couldn't regroup
and pursue roger covey we'll we will be
over 500 meters clear let the bombs fall
they moved quickly
soon rejoining their battalion hai and
doc lou were shocked they were alive
tired exhausted and dragging their
wounded the battalion gained little
ground moving maybe another 100 yards
before they heard the whistling bombs of
death hundreds of 500 and 750 pound
bombs demolished the nva forces on
charlie
the paratroopers hugged the earth duffy
and may lay prone under a tree that
shook like a wet dog showering them with
leaves as the ground shuddered violently
beneath them
a dark cloud of smoke rose from the
carnage of charlie
john lamented nothing could have
survived
two weeks of battle and an nva funeral
pyre
corpses corpses sit as the victors atop
their prize
i mean what do you think the battle
damage assessment was of that
yeah well it was it inflicted tremendous
damage on the enemy and and i i think i
mentioned later the impact it had on the
whole battle in the central highlands uh
it thwarted their plans to quickly sweep
down to take contume city and then cut
south vietnam in half
because of the damage that was done by
all those strikes and and what it cost
them to take charlie hill
that delayed their attack plans by a
couple of weeks which gave the
the south vietnamese an opportunity to
get another division up there and to get
all prepared to to take on this attack
against the the city of kantum
and in the end the south vietnamese
prevailed with a lot of american air
support
but they prevailed and the enemy did not
take contempt city their attack went no
further than that and they ended up with
withdrawing to uh
uh to
isolated positions really and until the
peace agreements were signed
the line was held yeah
uh these guys aren't out of it yet
though april 15th 1972 in darkness the
paratroopers followed major duffy down
the mountainside they carried those who
couldn't walk they struggled through the
tangled jungle exhaustion numbed their
senses even so
they still felt the pain that racked
their bodies infected wounds screamed
with every step in spite of their misery
hope swelled in their hearts as they had
left the carnage of charlie hill even
further behind
and then of course incoming there's a
there's a
a friendly fire incident that takes
place which is awful
um now they've got more dead
they got more wounded to carry they have
to leave some dead
hi
makes a radio call
to his headquarters red river this is
zero zero six we are off the mountain in
a northeast direction from our old home
at the base of the ridge i have about a
hundred and 150 many wounded request
helicopter extraction over
zero zero six this is red river negative
there are no helos available walk out
over
this is 006 roger out
duffy saw highs discuss what's up no
helicopter we walk
[Applause]
this is making me mad right now
and they're not they're not out of the
yeah not figuratively literally they're
not out of the woods yet yeah and then
of course the enemy struck rat attack
crack crack boom boom ambush
machine gun and rifle fire snapped
around them mortars exploded everywhere
enemy soldiers attacked from the trees
men dropped wounded and dead many of the
younger green paratroopers out of
ammunition and at their wit's end broke
and ran mowed down in their tracks the
nva 320th division commander positioned
a fresh force east of charlie to cut off
any withdrawal the second battalion from
the 48th regiment was waiting in
concealed positions they hit the
paratroopers hard john duffy raised his
weapon and shouted maylin we need to
break out of this gather all the men you
can i'll lead you cover me and follow
okay duffy we know surrender we fight to
death
john cocked his ar-15 and firing a few
well-placed rounds led a desperate
counter-attack amazingly they broke
through the enemy and found a refuge a
couple hundred yards north in the trees
along the stream duffy puffed we made it
how many do we have may counted 36 plus
you 37 total we have captain high
and doc lu and others
may directed high set a perimeter redis
redistribute ammunition to be sure every
soldier has at least some this is where
we'll make our stand
duffy's immediate thought was we need
air we need it now
he grabbed his handset to make a call
nothing [__]
may caught sight of his back duffy you
took a hit in the radio big hole it
finished you okay
duffy several times wounded bloody
filthy tired head throbbing body rife
with pain answered yeah i'm fine he took
the radio off his back and dropped it to
the ground he grabbed one of the two
small aircrew survival radios he had
clipped to his web gear turned it on and
transmitted on the emergency frequency
that all aircraft monitored any aircraft
any aircraft this is dusty cyanide
tactical emergency
us air force captain jim higgins a
forward air controller on his way back
to play coup
from supporting a special operation near
the cambodian border heard the call his
few was low but he responded dusty
cyanide this is cubby 555. covey dusty
cyanide we withdrew off charlie last
night i'm northeast of the hill in a
small valley just ambushed many killed
we broke out need helicopter extraction
i have 37 37 packs several wounded need
four helos roger dusty stand by i'll see
what we can rustle up
as you guys are out there on these
operations like over
does everybody kind of know who dusty
cyanide is at this point is everybody
tracking it by this time well we all did
because the panthers had been supporting
him now the unit that's going to end up
coming in to now save the day yet once
again is three five calf they've not
been involved in an operation up there
at all to this point so i don't think
that they
knew
dusty cyanide at that point but they're
soon gonna find out who dusty cyanide is
and once we get into that part of the
operation that goes to that audio
recording that i had that was recorded
by one of the air crews so
the dialogue in there is word for word
off that audio recording and i'd comment
on the dialogue in general i mean it's
it's a technique that i use for a
narrative non-fiction
but the dialogue obviously is is
recreated nobody remembers exactly what
they said but i took great care to talk
to each of the participants and they saw
all this dialogue as i developed it and
so they agree that this is very close to
the conversations that actually took
place so i use it to tell to tell their
story
but as we get into the into the the
pickup here
at the end that's word for word off that
audio tape of what was being said in the
in the aircraft
is dusty cyanide an issued call sign
yeah it was just a random randomly
generated generated issue i remember i
used to get those
uh then for some reason we started just
generating our own i don't know if that
was illegal or not but that's what we
did
uh i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
they they do get the they get the helos
in and
again this is really cool dialogue that
you that you quote and hear
between undertaker and embalmer these
are some good questions those are actual
call signs
good to go
undertaker 22.
now those aren't generated the air crew
call signs we had them for our whole
tour right that's like the panthers and
and they are uh gladiator was the
company's call sign oh for the uh for
the unit that worked sogg with us these
guys the cav yeah that embalmer
undertaker was their guns and bombers
their uh
is their lift ships yeah
uh
so these guys show up duffy radioed
cobra cobra they're 25 meters away
they're in that wood line go get them
roger dusty we're inbound keep your
heads down the cobras laid waste and
bomber 6 called short final the enemy
opened up with small arms and machine
gun fire a beat 40 rockets streaked past
the huey pulled up and turned sharply to
the left climbing the right door gunner
reported a jam at his machine gun he was
out of action no more protective fire on
the right side more enemy pressed in on
duffy in may they moved their group as
fast as they could go under undertaker
22 kept track of them dusty you still on
the lz are moving away from it we're
moving to the november roger i'll be
there i'll be in there with 20
millimeter still got small arms we moved
we moved another 100 meters we're we're
gonna stop here we got five people left
so over this period which i skipped
they're they're picking up like as many
guys as they can
and then they'd get shot out of a lz and
then they'd keep moving so they're down
to five guys left right this is the last
lift the last crew fourth lift
and bomber six began another approach
duffy popped his last smoke
gibbs transmitted i got yellow smoke
duffy warned still got small arms fire
still got small arms fire automatic
rifles undertaker added still drawing
small arms fire from the tree line down
there across the trees at your twelve
where the friendlies and the bad guys
are in the trees and bomber six
continued his approach duffy guided him
down to the ground the last five members
of the 11th airborne battalion scrambled
aboard go go duffy shouted
he stood on the landing strut his firing
his car 15 and helping the others in
an nva soldier ran toward the helicopter
his arm cocked ready to throw a grenade
duffy cut him down
lieutenant long kind climbed in followed
by corporal long captain high
and major may
crack a round blasted through the
cockpit crack another passed just behind
dennis watson's head it hit dallas nicen
is that saying that name right nasa
nielsen neeson neeson it hit dallas
neeson in the back as he fired his door
gun protecting the crew he pushed his
his intercom button hey hit
watson looked back their eyes held for a
moment then nissan's closed with
everyone on board duffy gave the other
door gunner a thumbs up and the young
man hollered on the intercom go go go go
get out of here
bullets riddled the chopper as it lifted
at 100 feet one smashed into hai's right
foot he fell backward out of the
helicopter john duffy still standing on
the landing skid grabbed hold of his web
gear just as he slid by stopping his
fall and certain death
with help from may he pulled high back
in may rendered aid duffy looked across
the helicopter and saw dallas neeson
hanging out the other side held by his
safety tether
john climbed in and moved over to dallas
pulling him back inside he patched the
wound to nissan's back with a plastic
sealer and a bandage he turned him over
dallas had a much larger hole where the
bullet exited his chest
it was bad
the wound bubbled the bulleted his lung
john started patching and sealing the
hole when the bubbles quit
dallas stopped breathing
john tried mouth to mouth nothing
dallas neeson died in john duffy's arms
it had been five days since the enemy
began their final all-out assault
against charlie five days of some of the
most intense combat ever fought
five days in hell
consigned to death but committed to
fighting with valor to the end
indeed it had been less than two weeks
since the 11th battalion fresh from its
duty in saigon had occupied firebase
charlie on easter sunday
but that was a lifetime ago their world
had changed
it was different from how it had been
and it would never be the same for any
of them
ever again
and thus ends
the battle for firebase charlie
yeah and as you mentioned
37 out of 471 paratroopers made it out
and and you did also mention that there
were some stragglers that came in right
there's gonna be another group of about
i think 20 that the artillery
fo lieutenant lap
rallies uh it took them several days
though to get back to friendly lines and
recovered and that's pretty well it a
few other stragglers but out of that 471
man battalion most
killed or captured or missing and never
never knew their status
john duffy wrote a poem
um
he ended up at the funeral of of colonel
bow posthumously promoted colonel bow
and
he he wrote a poem about that funeral
and again this is from his book which is
called the battle for charlie
it's called the commander's family
can you picture the scene
incense burning banners hung
casket draped
the moans and the weeping blend
[Music]
sorrow hangs in the atmosphere
the commander's comrades gathered to
offer their last salute
the young widow strong at first
but soon
sorrow overcomes her
it's not the smoke which tears my eyes
although i have lit seven jos sticks
the words are spoken for all to hear
now it is i who must say the last
i will say the truth
and how he died
he died leading the paratroopers he
loved
[Music]
he died fighting for the freedom he
cherished
he died
a hero
of his country
and that is certainly the truth
and i am certainly glad that you uh sir
have captured these heroics for
for all of us to hear and understand
and
you you mentioned this earlier
um we can be proud to report that major
john duffy
has been properly recognized for his
heroics
he was
awarded the medal of honor
on july 5th
2022 so just a few weeks ago
a few days ago a few days ago really so
you went out there for that ceremony i
did i was there in the white house with
him
with my wife and daughter
the daughter who he danced with on the
deck of the midway
to be present and it was it was quite a
ceremony long long time coming
uh i think i mentioned he was put in for
the medal of honor at the time peter
kama submitted him
it was downgraded to a distinguished
service cross
largely john feels because all the
eyewitness statements that he had at the
time when commas submitted it were
vietnamese statements
and
and so it was not supported
years later peter comma resubmitted with
the additional information had the audio
recording now
had some eyewitness statements by others
some of the air crews
but it took
forever to wind its way through the
bureaucracy
and and finally
got approval
and was presented on july 5th last week
to to him
quite a quite an emotional event to be
at
lavan may was there as well
there there are some you can you can
find it if you just do a google search
for john duffy medal of honor they've
got some video
from the white house ceremony
and uh as the president was making
remarks just before
hanging the medal of honor on john
he said that we're honored to have also
hear his vietnamese counterpart
leyvan may colonel leyvan may and may
stood up i had a suit on but his red
vietnamese paratrooper beret
saluted the president
it was quite quite a moving quite a
moving experience
well
that's just amazing that it that that
they did get it done and and that he was
awarded properly
so deserved i mean you've read medal of
honor citations before and this is so
deserving of the middle of life yeah i
can't imagine that the person that
downgraded this thing
i i get frustrated sometimes when i
think about the people that sit around
and downgrade awards
some tells me they probably shouldn't be
in the positions where they're doing
that
um
the the uh
another unbelievable part of this book
that i found to be fascinating and
inspiring
was
you know uh going into the aftermath and
what happened to everybody after the war
and really for me especially the
vietnamese
uh soldiers that
i mean what 19 wasn't very much after
this that
south vietnam fell yeah 1975. and so
these
individuals that had fought so
heroically
they all
had to either get out of there
uh
or try and get out of there
some of them
served in prison camps
and and they all had the goal of making
it to america yes
and it's also incredible what they all
did when they got here i think i think
it was may is it may that ends up he's
working as a janitor somewhere was that
may
uh he was yeah for a while and uh
and uh where where'd he end up he was in
missouri for a time yeah yeah i think
that was it he and again re get the book
and going to school he was working out
doing janitorial work going to school to
increase his education he ends up a
highly successful guy out here in
silicon valley by the time it's all over
and done yeah but it kicks off with him
being a i mean
highly decorated highly experienced to
say the least
war hero
and he shows up here hey hey well you
can you can you know sweep up and work
as a gender okay that's what i'm doing
then and then talks about that and and
how he made it through that and how all
of the you know all the vietnamese came
here all their kids do wonderful they're
all hugely successful
it's it's it's amazing to hear that part
of the story um
of how it all turns out for these for
these folks and of course never
forgetting the incredible sacrifices of
of the ones that didn't make it right
the ones that didn't survive or the ones
that didn't make it out of out of
vietnam
um and what a horror what a horror that
is
um
but man
the book is amazing like i said i i i i
read a small portion of it today less
than 10 of the book today get get the
book um so you can learn about it
and
get the full story and and by the way if
you haven't gotten
through the valley
that was kind of a for this podcast that
was sort of like a turning point
in my mind in the podcast just
how
powerful it was for me to be able to sit
here and talk with you
and the feedback that i got about that
podcast
because it's hard for a normal person
to comprehend
[Music]
the level of suffering
that a person can go through
and
a survive but then
go on and
thrive and
carry on with life and
and and and have
an amazing attitude
you know i mean we were talking a little
bit when we weren't recording and
you know you were you know your back's a
little bit sore or your knees a little
bit sore
um
and you're very thankful
to have a sore back and very thankful to
have a sore knee because if it wasn't
for a sore back and a sore knee the only
way for you to not have a sore back and
a sore knee would be you wouldn't be
here right now that's right i'd be
laying dead in a cobra wreck wreckage in
the jungles of vietnam i'm i'm very
grateful for every day that i've had
since that
i guess
when you go through something like that
i know i've talked to john duffy and lay
van may they they just
have pure joy for every day that they've
had since then every day since charlie
is a gift to each one of them
well
probably a good place to stop for now um
echo charles do you have any questions
no questions today it's it's hard to
have any questions after this
uh sir any any closing thoughts
no it's just you know this is an
important story so i'm glad that we had
a chance to discuss it at the podcast i
hope the story gets read far and wide
for for john duffy for lay van may for
heidwan those three central figures of
the of the book and just for the
vietnamese paratroopers because they did
exhibit
extraordinary valor really throughout
the throughout the war and they need to
be put in a category separate from the
arvin that are dismissed as as not being
heroic soldiers on the battlefield these
guys
certainly certainly were well you've
certainly
brought that to light and everyone that
hears this and read your book will no
doubt
understand the the bravery that they had
and
[Music]
thank you once again for for coming um
thanks for your service and sacrifice
thanks for your support to the troops on
the ground now that i have a bunch of
friends that were sogg
uh
they they love you guys so much for what
you did for them so thank you for for
supporting those troops on the ground
and and thank you for
your
s for your sacrifice as a as a prisoner
of war
uh
and the rest of your service in the army
i know that that wasn't even the end of
your career you know you went on for how
many years did you end up serving 30 30
years so that was just the beginning
so thank you for all your service and
thank you for taking the time and making
the effort to share these incredible
stories with us both your own personal
experiences and the experiences of these
other heroes so that we all can learn
and we can all be inspired
by you
and by
your comrades
and we can all
live better lives
knowing and understanding that true
heroes exist
thank you sir thank you
and with that
colonel reader has left the building
so awesome to be able to speak with him
again uh
and man
those stories are crazy
when you start talking about
having
130 millimeter artillery rounds land on
your position on a little knoll on a
hilltop
or you start talking about having 10
51 caliber machine guns shooting at you
when you're flying in a helicopter
those are those are those are not
possible
to explain
to a human i don't think you can do it
i don't think there's words to explain
yeah it doesn't seem and this is
me coming from a perspective of not very
much understanding and knowing the
magnitude
of these things especially you know i
know what i know what a 50 caliber
handgun
sounds like yeah feels like
yep
51 times 10 yeah getting shot at you and
those are way bigger than obviously yeah
right
and then okay actually this is a
question i did have though while i'm
listening
to this stuff i i just dismissed it as
something i'll never understand i'll
never i i won't comprehend it i don't
know the feeling i can imagine it or i i
can try to imagine it that's it i'm not
gonna imagine it i
understand that
but
these terms
artillery
what is that artillery yep artillery
is a form of what's called indirect fire
and what indirect fire is so direct
fires i aim a gun at you i can see you
and i shoot at you yeah that's direct
fire
indirect fires i can't i don't have to
be able to see you because it's going to
launch at a high angle up and it's going
to rain down from the sky okay
and that's what this is
these 130 millimeter cannons are you
know
a kilometer two kilometers away they can
be really far away you can't even see
them
and they're just dropping
big giant bombs on you from the sky
that's artillery and it's really
horrifying because you don't know where
it's coming from yeah and there's
nothing you can do to stop it it's it's
it the round got fired you know a few
seconds ago yeah maybe like even even
multiple like 10 seconds ago yeah like
that's how long their flight can be
their flight can be a really long time
so it's just coming and there's nothing
you can do about it now if you're in an
urban environment you can get overhead
cover that's cool that's you can survive
if you have overhead cover that's great
but if you're in a foxhole it's just a
it's just a matter of luck
yeah and
because it kind of seems like in that
way where it's like a matter of luck
even for the guys shooting it right some
level of luck for the guys shooting it
as well except for the fact that
when i i want to hit you
i'm not going to fire one i'm going to
fire 70. yeah and then my chances right
because that's exactly what they were
doing yeah okay we're going to hit this
whole hilltop yeah and you know like oh
you talk about mortars and stuff where
it's like and mortars are also usually
indirect fire yeah so it's kind of like
it's bad okay okay so direct fire right
let's say i don't know someone shoot and
they're getting closer or something like
that or
uh let's say you see oh i see a guy
pointing a gun at me or whatever i'm
going back i shoot back i can
move i can take cover kind of a thing
we can relocate
let me let's just go over there out of
the way kind of a thing
this is my tactical genius coming out
right now i know
but artillery is kind of like boom you
know you hear a mortar whatever where
are you gonna go
you could go into the to the in the line
of fire or whatever it's like just how
you could like avoid it oh yeah you
could go right into it as well it's like
you don't even know yeah it's just a
horrible horrible this is what you know
world war one when they would just
receive these barrages that's why they
got crazy shell shock yeah that's why
you see those guys that are absolutely
horrified
because they just got used to this
extreme level of horror and this level
of
it's like
you might think oh well it's just random
there's nothing you can do about it but
it's not even when you when you're
receiving 70 rounds it starts to not be
so random anymore they're eventually the
odds are they're going to get me yeah
that's what's going to happen
so then what is ordinance then because i
you know you hear like artillery here oh
heavy artillery or the just ordinance is
just the rounds anything yeah more gym
more of a general term yeah so yeah i
mean even
a bullet for a for a
handgun could be considered ordinance
but
so could the round from a tank or from
howitzer can also be considered or
ordinance dropped from an aircraft yeah
is a tank round
that's like what
120 120 is that artillery no
i mean kind no it's not technic it's a
tank round and a lot of times that'll be
direct fire yeah that's what i thought
all right
there you go yeah that's crazy man
a lot of times even when you talk about
it you know when you hear anytime i
think of grenades or
artillery in this case or whatever like
you know you imagine like the concussion
right because even shooting a gun is
more of a concussion than maybe the
average person might think if they
haven't been around guys what's the most
scared you've ever been in your whole
life scared
i don't know i mean i'm sure as a kid
i've been scared but i'm scared scared
did you ever think you were gonna die
yeah like in the water i was at waimea
one time like north shore on oahu and
it was big this is in my the height of
my cockiness in the water
oh and
i went out on a day they i there was a
actually the surf contest wasn't going
on in waimea but it was going on at uh
pipeline i think pipeline yeah and
so but the waves were huge it was kind
of when the waves hit like it vibrated
the whole beach and i was like oh yeah
go i'll go out they had lifeguards all
just lifeguards just
round robin just saving guys yeah yeah
were you on a boogie board no
body surfing
so i went out and
it it got ahead of me like for like
seconds at a time i didn't have to get
saved but um
that was how long did you stay out for
like 10 minutes i would say yeah so
imagine this imagine all that 10 minutes
how long were you really scared for in
that 10 minutes like two minutes two
minutes okay now picture that two
minutes compressed into
five seconds
and then multiply it times seven hours
like it's horror bro oh yeah these guys
are in horror yeah and you just don't
know what i mean and eventually it's
like okay well
eventually you have to have the attitude
of well
if it hits it hits yeah otherwise i'm
going to keep running around with my
radio on john duffy's style and just
keep calling for fire
or you go like oh how your mind kind of
goes into directions where it either
gets used to it or it gets like
overwhelming yeah like yeah your mind
gets overcoming yeah so like you go nuts
you go crazy kind of thing holy cow yeah
and then and then here's something i
can't really relate to but flying in a
helicopter
while there's 51 caliber machine guns
trying to shoot you out of the sky yeah
and that just
like
and you don't even know where they are
until they're shooting at you that's how
you get them as they start shooting you
see their tracers you cross your fingers
that they don't the tracers don't hit
you and then you engage them back
yeah
silver star citation for uh captain
reader for gallantry in action against
north vietnamese army forces 14 april
1972 while serving as a helicopter pilot
supporting the combat actions of
friendly vietnamese forces in canton
province republic of vietnam the
outnumbered ground forces were under
heavy artillery fire surrounded by
anti-aircraft weapons and under attack
by enemy forces captain reader took out
a number of lethal guns all while under
intense fire from multiple anti-aircraft
positions and small caliber weapons
after rearming and refueling captain
reader's team voluntarily returned once
again to engage the enemy in
extraordinarily poor conditions of low
clouds haze smoke and deepening darkness
his team prevented the friendly force
from being overrun captain reader's
actions contributed to the escape of
dozens of friendly forces and one
american soldier
his extraordinary heroism and selfless
sacrifice reflect great credit upon
himself
the 361st aviation company and the
united states army
and what's wild
that doesn't do this any justice at all
like you would have to go and set up
some sort of live simulation where
they're shooting 50 caliber rounds near
you to understand what this is
but then it's also interesting that he
you know he obviously received this
award and then goes back and just digs
out and finds all this more even
information about what he didn't even he
didn't even know how bad it was he said
it he's like i didn't know how bad it
was he just sees darkness and he's
shooting he doesn't even know that he's
killing hundreds of enemy attackers
so
just awesome to be able to have a person
like that here
um to share stories with us and if you
ever listened to podcast 63 yet go
listen to it that was
that's it
what he went through
is crazy it's crazy i was i was reading
through that book again
he thought he was going on they told him
it was going to be an 11 day march to
get from the prison camp he was in in
the south to get to the north they told
him his 11 days then it being he didn't
know if he was going to be able to make
11 days he's like i don't know if i'm
going to be able to do this he was
wounded he had dysentery he was famished
he
had infections all over his body his
ankle was like destroyed from his plane
crash or from his helicopter crash so he
doesn't think he's gonna make it
for 11 days it ends up being four months
of walking forced road march
and all that started just a couple weeks
after this happened
so
all right uh thanks for listening to
podcasts if you want to support the
podcast
and you want to support yourself
get yourself some chocolate fuel
by the way the drinks taste good now
you know what i'm saying i know what
you're saying yes we
reformulated all
jackal discipline go we reformulated all
the tastes but noticeably too that's the
thing too extreme it's not the kind
where oh okay you know you what you
added some more whatever you said we
reformulated the flavors yeah it's a
whole new deal and it used to be
hey you may or may not like this flavor
you may or may not like you might
actually not like this now it's like
you're to like them all yeah there'll
all be a nine and then one of them is
going to be an 11 and that'll be your
go-to yep and we all know which one that
is and but here's the thing though two i
like the mango now i didn't like the
mango at all before
that was kind of your jam you hit me now
yeah now it's our jam
the sleeper's gonna be dak savage dakota
meyer that one is just a whole another
level yeah it's still to me anyway the
ones that actually i didn't taste them
all i thought i tasted the
mango and one other one
and they taste to me the same flavor
just harder in that that direction where
it's like a good
like more robust just to be straight up
just to cut through whatever it is
you're trying to say they're all sweeter
now mm-hmm they're they're all they all
taste sweeter and sweeter tastes better
so
yeah jackoffuel.com if you want to get
some good taste and stuff molk by the
way
don't ever forget about milk
you can't forget about the mulk
because because when you're thinking i
need that sweetness
that dessert style what is it called
safe it's kind of savory and sweet at
the same time
yeah you're getting them both uh
jackalful.com yeah you can get mulk you
can get joint warfare
super krill just good stuff for you and
and and what
i'm gonna stand by
we don't cut any corners there's so many
corners to cut
when it comes to making
supplements there's so many corners that
you can cut we're not cutting any of
them yeah
on the drinks we're not cutting any of
them on jacob displaying gold there's no
corners been cut we could easily squeeze
another six cents out of this or four
cents no we're not doing that we're
giving you monk fruit we're pasteurizing
that's what we're doing it's across the
board
so there you go jockofield.com good
vitamin shop you can get the drinks at
wawa you know we have a you know we have
a ready-to-drink protein coming too do
you know that yes yeah the perfect
mix yeah well then is there such thing
in my household recently you know i got
just cut back from a trip
smoke is heavy in the rotation now you
know you get back on the program you
understand
well
for those of us who may or may not have
fallen off the program for a week or two
or whatever nonetheless moke is back in
but there is the point is there is no
perfect mix though can there be a
perfect mix if there is it's in the rtd
the region drink that you can roll in
and just get one that would make sense
like the most uh what do you say the
most accepted the most desirable mix the
peak of the bell curve flavor yeah yeah
yeah yeah because sometimes you know you
want to add a little bit of something in
there you want to add a banana you want
to add you know it depends on your mood
is what i'm saying
but
it'll be accepted widely we'll say that
we're rolling also heb down in texas
yeah we're in there we're starting to
hit
the major retailers across the country
convenience stores across the country
we're starting to get in there so
appreciate the support there
originusa.com
we're making jujitsuki's in america
we're making boots in america we're
making jeans in america and we're making
hunt gear in america get
come and check some of that out support
america
so i was wearing
dealt okay so my last day in hawaii
we're flying out we had an afternoon
flight so we go we go you know my kids
want to get shave ice i want to go
shopping but i'm wearing the you know so
i'm wearing delta 68 gene you know how
they're like
they look real nice
and you know you usually know why you
wear surf shorts or something like this
right but i'm wearing the like the jeans
and like shoes because i'm going to the
airport you know it's a whole thing
so my brother's mother-in-law
and the cousin um
his wife's cousin was were we ran into
them at the mall they were like oh what
are you all dressed up for
yeah
all i had was the delta
that's the way my my kids aren't so much
anymore but if my kids saw me wearing
jeans they would be like oh daddy why
are you so dressed up because they'd
never see me you know anything else but
surf shorts yeah flip-flops t-shirt uh
origin usa check it out originusa.com
don't forget about any of that get
yourself some jacquardstore.com stuff
too rashguard what else you got out
there got a lot of stuff discipline
equals freedom we got three versions now
got an updated version it's called
standard issue a standard ish standard
issue yep it's like this is the kind
this is the one there wait the standard
issue is new it's new yeah you see the
concept is new oh well put it this way
the concept i feel like should have
always been there and we never had it
that's what i felt i felt like it was
lacking okay so
it's a standard issue
i don't even think i've seen this one
yet no brand new
okay so there's some some color schemes
in there you may or may not recognize
hey in the industry don't they say
colorways
that sounds familiar for sure you got
some colorways oh don't do it though
don't do it to me don't do it to me i
shouldn't have brought it up now you're
gonna be throwing it out there i'm gonna
i gotta sound more official sometimes oh
but you might recognize them so
whichever one uh
resonates with you that's the one you're
gonna wanna get if if not you know
multiple whatever yeah either way we got
some uh
shirts hats hoodies they say good you
know that you just want to represent if
you want to represent the path do you
have a hat
a hat that says good no it might be a
thing to get it's possible going yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah noted uh we also got
the shirt locker the subscription the
one shirt every month so these are
different little bit different designs a
little bit different people like these
designs even people who don't know about
it they ask in my experience people have
asked where'd you get that shirt
for real i'm not joking but yeah you get
a new design every month uh that one's a
good one so check that out too if you
like that one all right awesome don't
forget about the underground taco
underground.com
we owe some of those right now yeah well
some jocko underground.com that means
we're gonna dig through answer your
questions we got a bunch of questions uh
that if you're on drockontoground.com
you can submit the questions we answer
them
so we'll get those out to you soon we've
got a youtube channel
i'm the assistant director
echo
just post some i guess yeah yeah he hits
upload is that what it's called
uh
got a bunch of books hey books here
through the valley
by william reader extraordinary valor by
william reader you heard me cover one of
them today you heard me cover the other
one in the past these are just
unbelievable books
only cry for the living by holly mckay
check that out final spin
you might want to get that book soon
before the movie comes out
so you kind of can get that vibe on it
which is cool
i written a bunch of other books on
leadership check them out speaking of
leadership
echelonfront.com if you need help inside
your organization go to echelonfront.com
we solve problems through leadership
we also have an online training academy
extremeownership.com you got a question
for me get go on to extreme ownership
dot com you can ask me that question
if you want to help service members
active and retire their families gold
star families
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a an
awesome charity organization
provides
veterans with help that they need go to
america's mightywarriors.org if you want
to help out also you got heroes and
horses.org
taking veterans out into the field
micah he's up there taking veterans out
of the field getting there getting their
brain body reset
that's what he's got going on and it's
awesome and if you want to follow
colonel reader he's on facebook at
william reader junior
and then also on the twitter on the
ground and on facebook echo is adequate
jealous i am at jocko willing of course
be advised
the algorithm's there and it's looking
to grab you once again
thanks to colonel william reader such an
amazing human being such an amazing man
such an incredible attitude
and thanks of course to the brave major
john duffy
major lay van may
and the rest of our allies our brave
allies in the 11th airborne battalion
who fought so valiantly
and to all the veterans of that war in
vietnam who did their best to protect
freedom in the world and thanks to all
the military personnel around the world
right now fighting to do the same
and the same goes to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service all first
responders thanks for what you do to
keep us safe here at home
and everyone else i want to leave you
with part of colonel william reader's
witness statement concerning john
duffy's heroic behavior
on charlie hill
he says quote
by the time our fire team of cobra
gunships returned to charlie the
situation had deteriorated dramatically
when we arrived it was dusk
major duffy had directed other attack
helicopters in our absence and employed
a1 skyraiders and jet fighters around
the firebase as well nonetheless
the enemy continued their attack and the
situation for major duffy and his
airborne battalion was deteriorating the
south vietnamese defenders were being
killed and their positions being overrun
major duffy told us he was wounded
but would continue to work us
[Music]
his focus on the radio was entirely on
doing what he could for his south
vietnamese comrades
at times while he had his microphone
keyed directing us i could hear him
giving orders to his counterparts who
were fighting for their lives
i could also hear him dealing with
casualties that were occurring all
around him
i never heard him express any concern
for himself
he would not ask for his own extraction
he seemed committed to fighting to the
death with his battalion
as the situation deteriorated further
he began asking for us to place our fire
within three meters
of his position
i have never seen greater bravery
displayed in combat
end quote
so there you go
there's the standard
now go live better
and until next time
zekko and jocko
out